[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Mic Check Mic Check what's going on
what's going on is you guys the ninja
himself look I need it was something
y'all wait for people to pull up what's
going on man
Jonathan B what's going on cat daddy
what's going on brother good we playing
destiny with you this week truck a hash
so shady what's going on
I see what we got seen you got enrolled
the finest my man you know says sir Luke
was going on make sure my levels is good
please make sure my levels are good we
just waited for attic and the crew to
come through everybody must have had a
rough night last night cuz they they are
late they are struggling well let me
know I'm allows your Frodo what's going
on man
all shout out to Dan Rodriguez you
already know season game in the pail
their true game is something that was
first today all right that was good
what's going on truck I had thank you
brother thank you
the geeky nerd guru survived oh yeah
yeah well my gig start right there mama
they'll take it personal survivor comes
up with what you know about that job to
be the geeky nerd were so he's like he
plays his game all about me while I'm
seeing that yo the geeky there we go I
did
big keith was going on thank you brother
so yeah we just chillin yeah I need
coffee - oh I'm about to get this coffee
going we got to get the realm right so
what attics should be pulling up usually
first solve is always smoothly like
right around town but I got to cut it
off the king because you know you're
gonna come in with a theme song we're
gonna get copyright strike we can't hit
I'll be back once they get up but other
laws getting around will do they mic
checks and I'll see y'all in a bit
[Music]
y'see black rider Wow that's what's up
so welcome to the wrong brother
I almost want to tell you don't join
until we go alive so you get the horns
and then I can see Jonathan peeing all
the old members get mad that the new
Bevers is getting the horse salute
welcome to the road brother welcome to
the realm no but yeah like I said if you
enjoyed the rub now we guys you got
something real special going on you know
with that and we working on back compat
horns we working on that for the old
members working on something all right
that's the out of it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh I see music with the $4 super chat
salute yo I gotta stop with the door hos
don't face yo you gotta check your attic
lettle pay your levels bro can you guys
hear me oh you read my in yeah yeah you
ready ready ready make sure y'all here
at it put put put some put some horns in
the chatter that might be the DEXA vote
you know the way they going let me go
yeah hieratic
oh he said he allowed this is he ready
oh yeah what about me what about me oh
the Savas pulled dumping the ground
smooth denzel but he got it sound
company you know saying damn right we yo
yo y'all gonna stop this no horns no
peace the AJ to live about her okay yeah
AJ he should be allowed on purpose I
know now so we just go wait for the king
I got a mute him cuz he gonna come in
any minute and blow up the whole
copyright you know sounds like he's
finally passed the sadness and a word to
get me where the get of the game phase
23 was gone oh yeah yay last of us yell
for million shows you you you you we are
the minority yeah absolutely absolutely
we go talk about all that mojo good to
see you brother you know how y'all bro
every time I see you in there it makes
me feel good that you're doing alright
well so anyway Oh mix mix are still in
the building
Frodo yeah we go talk about it I got I
got of you because a WK gonna be any
minute I'm not trying to cover
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feistiness boy boy lot of welcome to the
ILO's podcast and the Lords of gaming
got it Wow so buddy what day holds
hopefully the horse kicking soo because
we literally just pressed the boy so
hopefully but you know what we're we're
the horns and the Lords of gaming deck
episode number 164 and it's another
glorious Sunday we're back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day today we've
got halo infinite teaser cyberpunk night
CD wire mixer and Microsoft stores
closing and Phil Spencer's latest
interview to discuss so we gonna get
right into it so off you gotta take care
of them they are live right now right
now we got ready submit with the $20
chat to start off the day right Lord
addict we got you brother
we are iron Lords you will not walk this
walk alone yo I'm gonna be honest addict
like I I don't like once I saw that I
was like man listen brother like you're
not the type necessarily to do water and
you are with us but not necessarily out
there and I was I was moved by that
I heard the horns shoutout to all was a
rata miss a Vitamix prom that's was so I
think that what I miss ya
you gotta wait a sec you gotta wait for
the kick in ahead you gotta see he means
his home we work it all back up at horns
we working on replicas bees laughing
right now I was up it was about 11
o'clock right so I start setting up you
know I like to sit down and prepare for
the show whatever early so I come in I
go to the break it up everybody get up
let us know
[Music]
wow really loving these [ __ ] alright
we got a fight on super chat from
Jonathan B wonder what all the [ __ ]
aren't working huh I turned them off I'm
on my a tree Lord's baby
King get that tat yet no we got to start
the show yeah stupid the name anyway
my pockets bro introduce the for speed
of gaming the original Lords here at the
round table
well Cohoes with the Cobos my brother
from another mother the different Jesus
Christ our Lord of reviews and the half
of the young book Bobby Lord addict I do
sir
I'm doing pretty good you know first
thing I want to say is I want to really
appreciate the community for coming
together from our cousin uh I woke up
this morning to air and Greenbury Tweety
you know it's just it's one thing to see
the community come together for other
people it's another thing for them to
come together for you and you know what
I saw that I was like I was like wow
like I was speechless like I sent it to
to his dad and his dad didn't even know
what to say he was just like I didn't
expect that and you're I just once again
I want to thank everyone for wheat wheat
and anyone that donated you know anyone
that liked the support is definitely
noticed and I appreciate it all yeah I
just want to put in the chat right now
put it back in and got the GoFundMe you
know saying this is for all your cousin
right little cousin yeah it's mine two
years old he's going he's got leukemia
and I'm a brother brother you it made me
cry this well I was just like man you
don't wish that on no no Chuck
especially some child starting his lungs
saw in his life like this so go to the
community
Greenberg um it's funny the horns went
off when I said a home but it was just
tremendous to see everybody get behind
you because I know you attic doesn't put
himself out there like that you know I'm
saying so there were situations real so
god bless and hopefully he gets the
treatment and everything he needs in a
positive note or anything you've been
playing I know you got a lot of videos
going on going out and stuff was go
don't you so I've been playing I've been
playing man
I've been playing fable I've been
playing a lot of Star Wars Battlefront
actually I've been playing that a game
he's going on it is I was actually I was
playing it for fraudulent reasons all
right forget for video game play that's
all then I ended up playing it for three
hours
shout out the graphics yanking you in oh
oh my god you're a savage right now
first of all let's get the people we
welcome to the row put them cress in the
chat oh no it's just no elite mom Lynn
welcome to the real Toby was nice then
we have Z black rider with a $20
Canadian deal 20 maybe in Dallas for
chat just hoping addicts find a barber
oh oh wow
Danna that Billy go stay for like at the
very least till we get the overalls in
the quick thanks world to death let's go
ahead and do this sense let's do this
now all right you're obviously
we obviously you guys have been so good
to us with the memberships that we've
been able to get another emo so what
we're gonna do is we're going to let the
members and the patreon us decide we're
gonna add them up by next week and then
you will be debuting the new emote next
week so we're gonna go over them right
now obviously addicts world put you at
example
I'm low-key not even wanting this in
there because I know what you guys are
gonna use it for
all right then we've got your go ahead
and stop that we got on Garden dim oh
yeah so first we got which they all got
in them yes sir yes sir
caught up all right then we have onto
something yeah you know now come on yeah
I know what that's only you're honest no
and then we have the famous horns so we
definitely we're gonna get that took
care of obviously we didn't have the you
know the the live animated one for
freyal feet but after this podcast I
will go on patreon I will go on the
membership I will make the poll and
whatever you guys pick is what's going
to be put up next week go home no geek
either said no truck and Kate and keep
in mind there are a couple of you lords
that are double dipping so your vote
will count one yeah absolutely so if you
in there two times most technical gaming
Lord the solo game of list for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Damas mr. Flom profile
Illuminati and lower patron of the iron
baked mommy
Lord sovereign how we doing sir what's
going on fellas
chillin what's going on me you know what
I've been doing man Oh thoroughly so
yeah man I've been getting down and I
have some updated impressions and
so first of all that yeah that's why I
did beat that I beat that oh yeah that's
right can we get yeah I was at the very
end of the game so I'm at the very very
very end
okay I'm not I'm not there yet so maybe
versus how we all got all the four
millions at a beep I don't can go get
all number oh no no no listen when does
my baby so the first thing is I remember
how I kind of criticized the hub area
for kind of slowing down the pace and
whatnot yes what I realized was that I
mean a one thing parsley that's my fault
cause I play super slow right now
I really look at everything so I slowed
it down even more so right um but what
that area did for me was give me context
for my enemy Brandon thinks that for my
enemy and what they're going through and
in addition to that meaning that they
have enemies as well right
it gave me context for like the greater
overarching story in a way that I
thought was good so again the snow Li
the slowness of it yet there is a bigger
area that I expect to see in that game
but I did take it extra slow extra
question are you gonna be with Eric and
I are when we do fire I know I'm not
there yet I'm not even closed
like that's not a Tuesday though no I'm
not gonna oh no it's no way I'm me I was
telling our southern cog we're gonna
need to do a second small game while we
just wait feel nice long it's gonna be a
while hopefully I'll finish by the end
of this week great we know how to solve
is way out we yeah wait so that's the
first thing right so the second thing is
yo man
like the gameplay this is straight up
their best playing game mm-hmm
no it's all straight up like you would
have to go back to
a Bandicoot and jak and daxter to find
gameplay sort of rival just in terms of
tightness of gameplay I said last week
that going prone and what they've done
with stealth is a game changer in this
game it is you know was you know you saw
her you know they stole you remember um
where was it a math Splinter Cell yeah
it was Splinter Cell Conviction remember
the one that never came out when he was
looking like Joel you really just like
him in that when how it goes like
general right when well yeah when he
looked he was bearded and shovel Lord he
was using the environment for stuff yes
he threw the bottle - yeah he was
throwing the bottles and he would slide
behind people it was it was an idea
before its time is totally Sam Fisher in
that game but I tell you this the
widdy's at the stove it is fantastic
like I'll be honest if they gave her
like Batman had to hand combat like some
kind of Krav Maga something like that
yeah this game is the best John wick
game ever made like her hand to him it
is so brutal when she is with that knife
is yo and [ __ ]
I took a hatchet to a dog's head and
that yo yeah I tell my son in the Gulf
stairs yeah again you don't need to be
watching any of this you know because
there's gonna desensitize you to or a
level of violence that you feel that
when violence does happen you don't you
know shock away from you know move away
from it and I think that I think you
know really this game should be actually
monitored to the children that are
actually playing this game oh no no not
at all it's one of the very few games
that's like maybe this needs to be rated
more than em it should be rated on No
the exact though it's really especially
when you give those animations for like
stabbing people's necks like that that
gets crazy old or oh we got the bro in
there our GT up in a bit too much et's
in a building you already know [ __ ] oh
my man big club yo big mouth I got to
tell you something real quick oh around
so he said it salute to my brothers
island podcast hey David it's a go bro
so oh we got it
yeah that was a go whatever it is
somebody my last thing my last ik the
music in this game
talk to me it is it evoked in me the
same feeling I had when I watched The
Dark Knight for the first time oh wow
talk talk talking you talking go talk
you know the moments when the moments
when the Joker came on screaming and you
would hear like a low siren in the
background to show the drama was coming
yeah and it was a low sort of wailing
siren in this game when you drop into an
area right a lot of times you drop into
an area and immediately
it'll be swarmed by enemies right you
know you sniffing you out you have
enemies and then the music ramps up and
in a way it has it's a it's a siren that
you sort of hear that sort of simulates
a beating heart hmm
but it's not like a loud like a like a
wailing siren it's a deep side I thought
it was outside of my house it's in pace
with your heartbeat so yo do it the way
it sets the tone for those gameplay
moments is really like I had to sit back
for a minute like our bearings and see
what mean it the music so far in this
game sets the tone in such a way that it
elevates every gameplay moments like
sounded off the chain then we get that
girl that um did the south she's a
Microsoft Network host a lot of talents
talents - thank you
like you you not i gotta be like me i'm
super the tatical slow yeah you just
immerse yourself probably 20 hours in
but I'm not you're 20 hours in the name
then I'm at 23 hours and he searches
every nook and cranny he goes there
isn't a whole lot of nooks and crannies
always the type for what I saw correct
me if I'm wrong no type that is like he
could pass a section but if he didn't do
it stealthily correct he go do the
section over oh you oh you are those
dude yes I'm one of those people that I
try to do a stealth and I really do us I
scan everything that do you scanned
no like I'm walking around scanning the
battlefield finding where everyone is
I'm not using weights off you're not
using the oh no no no no not is too much
how we do wrong like that's what did
should it be that requires you eight
right so we're not anytime I get into
combat scenario first look for is high
grass yeah or the or whatchamacallit or
high ground yeah high ground the roof or
something like that a window that I can
scan area okay using you are putting
yourself on hard mode and not using that
what is the shoutout to job solicit mode
well you know that's a violation for you
what you're doing is you're pulling a
Cognito on purpose you did use one of
the features the whole game because you
didn't know it existed know about that I
forgot a fantasy oh yeah you did you no
matter the high spells fire off
cool
we gotta go get like literally every he
would look everyone use care terrible
yeah I think it was um you know who
exposed me it was a hectic shout them
from Basra channel for lunch gave me
that day he was like bro you know that
you just gotta move the arrow to the
side and I'm like oh I don't know buddy
anyway so that's been this sauce off do
it yeah real quick a cat daddy with to
those who said the last of us was so
visceral I had to take breaks yeah it is
it it is come on your clothes
yeah we got a big cloud no all I'm gonna
hit you up in the DM at David mm burglar
I know now you're and of course we have
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS
gamer rule the lord of combat sports
king of the statues experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert like anybody
that's Kings knees and they're ready to
ship 200 I'm just sayin I got one of
your knees in underneath
Robo I could not stop laughing yo it's
like when you open up a fresh bag of
Pringles
you mean the barbecue sauce on West
Virginia knees so check it out guys
all right um if anybody checked me out
on open mic the statue group just oh
yeah dark at a castle or channel like
follow subscribe go over there check
that out every Fridays at 9 p.m. is in
is lit get a little wild get a little
crazy we'll be talking about these
statues and comic books and stuff and
we're also talking about the Last of Us
there so you know I'm bringing the video
game flavor there to the group you know
cuz we all intertwine we all collect so
it's something if everybody it's a anime
if you're into horror everything
everything is there everything is
covered um please go check that last
word it was a very powerful last word
I'm not gonna get too deep into it but
check out the last word trust me it's
it's a lot more than destiny going on in
that last word Thank You boss Brooke bro
eazy-e I'm just soon man I really
appreciate his friendship you have no
idea like the last two years especially
growing closer and a lot of day ease a
real one he's a real I didn't know how
really well we I have my radio ready to
pop off or buy in trouble you sir first
game passes for those people who have
game paths captain game passes here to
save you
so I definitely want you guys to go
check out the messenger the messenger
and I downloaded like a game that was
like a Streets of Rage type of game but
is like an 8-bit game your chance to
play that one is like speaks of the
broke the wrong cheater oh here get that
message you know we interviewed them we
was their first indie game of the year
shout out to my boy Lord saboteur all
that man yo because alou man we covered
it first we got all the DLC coverage up
while ILP check out the PAX East content
man message if you haven't played it
Xbox guys you won't love it continue
it's a beautiful game a a bit love
what's the game 16-bit and it goes back
and forth crazy team um first of all is
my game buddy yeah oh I don't care what
comes out for rest of them upwards
chapter we doing this we don't want to
go oh here
what comes out wow this big for the game
first of all I'm in love with that no
that's easy it's interesting a B that's
strong easy like a girl with muscles oh
wow you got nor the jeez say wow Chad
the missing oh wait wait wait this is
goat do you suppose could not be allowed
to light and buy other games and systems
I'm gonna tell you this mmm it is
probably the greatest story game of a
told whoa
and if and if a lot of you a lot of you
dudes be on the fence up nah this game
is like Ferrari about but did you a
because I heard ending oh oh no no I
know I'm at and I'm gonna end it may be
right came downstairs Wow right um
because you know I had sent cog some
statues things that I was getting
and we talking right I gotta make it to
the show I was gonna telling you hold on
5 10 minutes man but you know I didn't
finish it off oh I'm in a room and said
kid I said negative super Chet shot the
Lord back see in a row we go give me
your Crescent a minute but I'll continue
so you know it made me crime mom
literally III sat there with tears in my
eyes and it's not a scene that might
invoke it from a lot of people but as a
heartfelt scene because I have daddy
issues okay right so it's a scene with
that and that that oh that game isn't
afraid to go there wherever it there is
dank but we're gonna do it on a spoiler
cast I am aware every winner is it's not
afraid Wow and for you fraud individuals
all that claim Sony and rep it and don't
have a pro I'm getting I'm getting your
guts right now polls because I'm tired
of you dudes on my timeline with your
basic TVs in their states and regel is
not supporting Sony you don't got a VR
I've noted backhanded compliment
supporting them to the fullest because
I'm out here 100% supporting them to the
fullest hold on Kerry said by you
I'm gonna watch your pockets because
let's get some pocket watch it in that
chatty Co and remember I'm gonna look at
every last one of you because this is
how your frauds come in now it is a
hundred and thirty-five million players
oh here we go
135 million players do we go this game
knew the game was coming it was coming
since the last of us one came out mm-hmm
so y'all was waiting for part two your
sword since 2016 grab dude this is bucks
but since 2016 I get $60 to get this
game million people strong were
purchased it that's it it's a problem so
let me tell you something here's the
problem with few guys mm-hmm since you
don't want to purchase and yes so
against impasse if game pass was on a
Playstation and that game release date
and date more eyes will be one again
you're not a game player you talk about
you want to play games you love games
but you always giving me numbers oh we
sold 20 million one copy bro sit down
and sit down and be quiet a lot of you
dudes are new to the PlayStation fence I
knew these boots I got to get this off
my chest because you guys be on my
timeline I don't forget or more than you
now let's go when I can run out and go
get the game that you love and you ain't
get it yet but you in my mentions and I
know who you are so you stop mentioning
me it's completely shameful so if you
got a PlayStation mm go out and get it
or have Jim run a gym dance moves
running put it in PlayStation now
subscribe the PlayStation now more eyes
can get on again demand more demand
better I'm still stuck on the fact that
you said Last of Us has the better story
mmm that is game of the year look man at
the end of the day man we got to get
some fried alerts in that shaft for that
story
visuals that wonder bitchin moon you
guys don't wanna [ __ ] a moan about a
story
mmm you did not write that you're not
Naughty Dog's and you don't control the
characters y'all entitled but sit down I
don't know what happened it's a story
that Naughty Dog wants to tell God now
you have a problem with that story
mm-hmm no actual refund hey I'm not
gonna ask for a refund right you doing
if you play the game right so it's in
just like a book maybe you might matter
I don't like the way he went into the
water
I seen [ __ ] though you are not in
control of the characters go write a
game make it game or petition to change
no King no I gotta give you this you
only something from this point on
and again I've purposely I'm scared of
this game I'm not gonna this is the
first game I'm literally terrified to
play because I have people on both sides
that I trust tremendously and they're so
diametrically opposed to their thoughts
on this game like that there's a strong
contingent that's with you there's a
strong contingent like they butchered it
so like I with you at this point okay
great is that name we're told the I'm
with you this way breathe the way
certain people feel like with service
franchises there's a definitely
emotional connection right so my whole
thing is like you said if you saw in you
see like don't support it then right go
by but people still running out there
and we saw the sales we saw what sales
this so it's interested is it just a
gentleman is this is crazy this is who
we got Smitty Smith for to follow
through chat shout out to Lord of boxes
Lord car has to be excellent to each
other
oh thank you brother from the last word
he knows and we have said Lord maxi put
them crest in the chat welcome to the
ground sirloin bro boys one deck I heard
him yeah I saw the money here the bad
then we are currently down at your your
guys make you guys make me wanna stop
final five seven and start the last
crazy no no we have or we jumped a
little bit hold on we jumped a bunch
actually give me a second Wow okay okay
we have big cloud gaming Wow nobody dog
took David's knees Digital knees pull
the stitch with that King that now you
watch said now you know why I said this
game should sell more yeah a bunch no
yeah pixel bit cheap the - ah super chat
I love in gives equal shade and praise
thank you yes oh you all it's a
corporate shield podcast I don't get
that real basic TVs are no Pro and
regularly dad again with the Fosters
yeah he's on something most of us
opposed to buyers are probably Xbox
dudes anyway old by we are regulating
with the $2 super chat preach King
preach have a blessed morning Lords
likewise to you my brother Jonathan me
with the five dollar super check this
speech to took such a turn I was not
prepared we gotta give to update
everybody that joins in the realm
looking for the tattoo on Thursday being
this colvett situation is going on the
way that you go to tattoo parlors now is
well I had to make my appointment in
Omaha I made my appointment and they
have a whole bunch of rules and
stipulations about you know getting
there and so the dude because this is
the fourth of July weekend my birthday
is on a 4th of July weekend from the
first go to 4th they're not there right
so I'm scheduled for the 11th and I
think is at 11:30 a.m. I put it in our
chat oh that's when I'm scheduled to get
the tattoo
I spoke to will me her to let him know
you know he not ripping off for that
stuff anyway
but um you
deserve it and that's what that's the
day to be up so you guys can check it
out so right before we go to ILP that
day like it see it also it was a another
oh there's a quick story okay so when I
was my mother sent me to the store to go
um I mean to go to pay the verizon bill
it was AT&T at the time to go pay AT&T
y'all numbers throw yeah but I know she
iris also saw this Donkey Kong game the
Pocky game so alright so what I did was
I went and she never checked the phone
bill ever ever ever
so let you take them put in the drawer
so this time I go in there I purchase
the Donkey Kong and then I went and took
the rest of them I was responsible I
just blow all the cash I took rest of
the money and I went and I paid the
phone girl like 90 bucks right in the
pocket game was like 37 something like I
don't know I paid it off oh my friend
Hubert I'm like yo you were walking me
home then I come back outside you know I
just want to you know give my mom's to
build then I come back outside
yeah see she acts this is your game
responsibility so he was playing it so I
put it in my pocket I walk in the house
so I walk in the house I get my mother
to be us I'm gonna go back outside
she said you gonna say my friend you
boots outside she saw the Bulge in my
pocket the box to beatings were
legendary
so she see she goes oh this is Hubert I
think it was dead your reply
nun applied it all
she didn't get the squeezy nothing it's
9:00 in the face Hubert oh just exactly
what I thought and slam the door so I
proceeded to get my butthole a duster
will be hood be it's a chicken oh she
took me back to the store no and said I
want my money back selling this to a
child oh shout out to my Arab friend
all sales are final but so get back to
the house right now all right that's
what happened I didn't get into up then
cuz she thought she was looking on money
back
shoutout to my mom's working and going
school thanks so much you go to school I
scoured the house looking for I will sit
there and play Donkey Kong with my
little red button on my pocket watch
story went and this was a crazy story
we got a little we got pieces of it
before and then we got some of the
discipline stories or movie hood baby on
a box was hilarium rolling cuz beatings
was legendary back in the day your
parents would not have been probably
allowed to do what they were doing
we got a catch up yeah a bunch okay yeah
one way dragons TV route to two dollar
super check one away drag is TV has
entered the realm Oh congratulations on
one K 1 over 1000 subscribers brother
that's North lien small fee could take
continued in fact then we have phase 23
became when I would the file a super
attack King when was the latter game
xbox sold four million in two days
I don't know about what I can say is did
you body game mentions yet again do you
have okay television do you have a probe
do you like I do bro nope so now you
know daddy with the file off so it's at
crazy how people refused to buy it
because of the story but we'll watch an
entire plate then again like like I feel
like you giving exposure to it on
Twitter and stuff is almost just as bad
as you buying it like if you don't if
you're not about that story just don't
watch anything to do with it like
continues always catch up slow-mo with
the fight off super chattin I will not
say the last of us to story is bad it
just doesn't live up to the level of
storytelling from the first game also
leave my teeth yellow fabrications
it's a greatest story it's a great game
it's tenfold better than the first game
literally wish it could do what the
second game not knowing what happens
what not my thing
I've seen people outraged and I think BG
touched on this last week worse I mean
it's not just it's not giving you the
happy ending you think you deserve bro
and I'm like and if you mattered it
because of that and say the story's no
good because of that you know like you
know you know understanding the world
that they built I feel you saw the only
counterpoint I heard again to the things
I've seen that spoiler is that they felt
that they don't have an issue with not a
happy ending but something about they
don't feel this was deserved or the the
reasonings behind it they had problems
where it was more of it or something
like to that effect that's why I don't
know what King is on what's its so
Caguas and I want you to play this game
song so best you know how right I am
that level of motivations for each and
every character is completely clear I
want you to play this game so we so we
could talk on disk or the foul
we could talk on disagree what King was
smoking today
Cory Hale in a building because this
turned into a last of a podcast I'm like
it what happened that time we got things
we got the reward we are going to I'm
going to surprise there will be other
people on my squid look so catch a [ __ ]
at happy early birthday Lord kill a
brother thank you and then we have let
me see we got we got Shastri with the to
LA super chat hallo for three point six
million in 24 hours okay
he's running around here with you but he
just got a PlayStation so he don't know
that there was games that came out
before you know yeah we're good and of
course Lord Cory hey guys Dovie guy look
I need him spread their realness to the
robot I'll feed I tell you what you
ought to have what you would need to
hear shout this stitch for the Tennessee
would share already for those of you
asking about numbers just know that when
Microsoft puts a game out it reaches
ninety plus millions millions millions
because it goes on K pass okay you see
the MS in a minute but yeah man sort of
reason I have not been caught up and I'm
in I am in the bushes with our last of
us has been because destiny has been
good y'all
that's this good kognito is inefficient
as it very big it doesn't play anything
so shout out to a lot of people but I
got a shout out first of all shout to
the last word
my brother he bonds his man like King
said we had some powerful discussion you
know I'm saying right quick cuz
obviously you know even going to detail
but that's the community kind of bursts
of movement that has kind of gone into
the rest of the world and it's not the
prettiest thing I mean yeah a lot of
people who got [ __ ] else in the
community based on behavior and things
that are not accepting that's an utter
statement at this point yeah so this has
spread in to corporations and streaming
service is another platform and it is
crazy we had to talk about it because
it's pertaining to dudes who hating on
my bro and on his channel you know I'm
saying like we didn't say anybody name
we didn't you know talk about anybody
specific case you know I'm saying so at
the end of the day we just got to talk
about the community and how it did
affect the community so stop coming at
my bro he's a good dude and proud to
podcast up so you check that out he was
doing it up on the last word it's not
down to having clear you live you gotta
read that Jenna the because I got a
super Jeff from Jonathan be on the patch
look man I don't want that a few people
go shout out to my bro for wicked good
gamer good Dom got a little desti or or
Xbox for a little bit I also deal to 30
frames and I was out there for days
dogmeat is about we was rockin out the
cloud I came down oh god I had to come
down from Universal frames the field of
view and all the nvme yeah so shout out
shout out about my editor-in-chief shout
the jaws reading Oh him an apology I
quote about our last word because I
didn't play the prophecy dungeon
because I was waiting for him and then I
called them out like yeah you're the
reason why because everybody asking
y'all wanna go play not by not waiting
for Josh and it was actually me it was
awful day I held it up but he's like cog
I got the dibs yeah I was waiting for
you to mess with me back when we
supposed to play so I was on you on my
you gotta be so shop yeah shout out the
card box - we got the prophecy done it's
amazing amazing bungees in a bag again
one of the best tons you know going
celebs under them is Chris of main Yost
get to see the chest in his room so we
got a $2.00 super chat from somebody
submit IV was straight-up Brock bombing
dudes yes I like a strong condo del goes
out so we all caught up with dad no I
like a girl can't wait to see V come on
in here and I'm here because I got the
phone call to platform damn it's like
that about this bad the best oh you like
this Jerome a craft Darumaka kudos to
Pratap please say something brother
so we can shut you out alright cool so
with your court up solve attic we caught
up with the news all that stuff I get
you
not cool so last week's poll results
again the people have spoken to the
question with the recent controversy
regarding the last of us to review
embargoes do you mind media outlets
should be able to review a game while
being restricted from mentioning the
entire game in the same review the
winner of our 3-way ILP poll at 56% of
the vote was no it should be listed as
impressions or review in progress group
coming in at second at 23% was yes major
plot spoilers must be protected and at a
very close last place at 19% kind of
close I don't care it's all fun and
games until you leak the entire game on
the Internet to all the people
participated shout out to spider-man
into our chat imagine turning on the PS
Bob and hearing King Saudi baby every
time I take a watched LittleBigPlanet
that voice come along again people voted
and said that they agree with what you
were passionate about which is the game
should have had impressions only instead
of a full review based on the embargo
good then those right there those are
the real ones
okay the other ones that voted the other
way it's a little bit we got to get into
these topics a lot of show so attic I'm
back was gonna go back to you we gotta
set it off
um yeah man so this is subject to the
direct insurer 199 Lockhart and game
past packing no cart with code means
every console signs up along with the
halo push it'll pay for itself
look no attic man we got to get to it
man big T's happened this week so I got
to go to you cuz I'm a law fraud here in
the or Halo universe I don't know what's
going on for the most part you are the
educator please tell us the significance
the employers what is going on with this
teeth so right now we've finally got our
information we haven't really seen
anything so we finally got our new
information on infinite and what
happened on Halo Infinite is it was
pretty much a disgrace call its it was
someone from a tree auxes camp and they
were pretty much saying that you know
there's they're making statements about
the profits they make a statements about
human kinds and they want them
obliterated you know they they said at
the beginning of it that you know we're
wood on the process and here soon we're
gonna have control over a ring so you
know being that this is like the the
first information we really had on this
game and forever since the last year at
e3 pretty much I wanted to bring to the
room you know let's talk about this you
know the height for this game and what
your expectations are with this game now
that we know that they vanished are
officially in the picture all right so
just school me real quick I get it full
of frauds again this is for the front
alert isn't me I'm definitely halo Lord
for him
what is the banish it aatrox is - dude
you were schooling me about or in halo
wars - so he's the big
bad yes so pretty much a tree ox is a
brute that is in a clan that for some
reason I guess the Covenant doesn't like
now I don't know if it's tough they
don't like them but it seems like they
love sending these people out on suicide
missions right right the company okay
yeah they send them out on 40 at a time
they're pretty much headhunters for the
Spartans they they're all their
objective is to do something impossible
and chances are they're gonna die doing
it now real quick just for clarity and
you showed me to hit a troll 2 halo wars
- and you're may 8th Shox was very
famous like and he was roughing up
Spartans and he killed one so this dude
no one he injured him injured him but he
was not be taking LZ he's handing elves
- oh he definitely handed him a now but
he didn't kill him ok because later on
in the game you used him again
ok so he is I put it this way I'm just
trying to build him up he is a drink
like this yes he is a brother oh yeah I
unless they [ __ ] him in Infinite I think
you could take G yeah ok I'm liking what
I'm hearing let's get into it
oh I'm so it's gonna be one of those
scenarios where they jump patriarchs I
could almost get I got questions I solve
let's get it to a bed did you watch the
trailer the teaser was going ok was wait
yeah
so real quick let's do this these super
test real quick we got one-way dragons
to follow switch at I'm going with King
winning over Abby did you see his video
on Twitter sweating like he was running
from the cops and we have Gerald Mac
gonna fight ah super sad why is no one
talking about the Marvel Avengers game
looking pretty good to me oh now they
gotta eat all that cruelty not hungry
with the $5 to protect we are his will
we are his prophecy legacy we finish it
leads me into why a tree ox is me he
reminds me you know how King King is
it's a big fan of Ultron and yes it no
it's not because Ultron
within his classification as a villain
his villainy is very much a perspective
thing he's he is right in his mind and
he's right for a number of different
ways and he's an his cause is noble and
a tree ox to me is in parallel with him
a tree ox is somebody who never bought
into anything the profits I don't
believe in a prophet spoke up pretty
much happen is at he it's like I was
saying he was set at 40 at a time and
he's the only one it was every time he
was the only one to come back and if you
look at his his hammer because he's got
a special hammer mm-hmm every hammer
he's got these marks on it for I assume
every time he went on the suicide
missions oh he's got like 50 of them
owning pretty much you know he kept
going out he kept coming back and then
you know sooner or later these people
ain't trying to help me
he's like I'm seeing all my fellow
brutes die and he revolted and because
he was so popular he was so well-known
he was so respected because he kept
doing these suicide missions and the
only people to cover the only person to
come back he inspired people to revolt
with him he did at the moment of his
execution he was supposed to be executed
for being defiant I in that moment he
murdered the the saint golly who was
gonna cut his way he boarded an Old
Covenant
oh yeah yeah he is the banished is
literally exactly as the names called
they're banished Oh Eddie litter okay so
the name is fitting they are banished
there then he's got his own squad you
know the cool thing about a tree ox is
when Isabelle's talking she's like look
we almost lost to the Covenant mmm she's
like at the time they were fighting us
and on the other universe they were
fighting the banished and this is like
he's like they they almost beat us
anyone that it shows a tree ox he's like
but him they didn't even come close so
he got mad ghouls he's banished they
were oh yeah
he's probably just as much as the
Covenant did at their height so he feels
like he has brutes right but he's also
man as the turns and Gallio so so it's
like he has everybody yes everybody and
that's where that's where to me the
Ultron comparison comes in because
within what he does there he is
he's about pride he is about um honor
his motivation motivation is race like a
Thanos his motivations are really wrong
is he been done dirty he didn't believe
in the prophets which are saying and now
he coming with his team Connor he's one
of those people were it's been stated a
couple times you know the Covenant is
you know dictatorship where the prophets
dictate everything aatrox will let you
speak your mind but if you keep speaking
of too many times I mean if they put
this man at the forefront of this
conflict hmm I'm super excited for him
the sound fire the greatest part aatrox
has ever said in this game is when he
beat he I'm pretty sure he needed to
beat her own or the Douglas was wrong he
beat up and they're dragging him out of
the out of the place out of the place
that a tree ox has his helmet and keep
in mind these helmets that the the
Spartan suits are huge and they're heavy
he had his home in his hand he said just
like I thought he's just a man historic
sighting patriarchs thinks that that's
like Master Chief he doesn't know the
demon mm-hmm so he hasn't fought the
demon yet but I don't believe that the
demon is gonna be enough to beat him so
he the basketball boom and it's gonna
be smart a lot let's go before Spartans
on one but we gotta bring up that that
you know Alice Jerome and Douglas they
are not full-blown Spartans like why are
you gonna get smug grin on your neck he
says not Jerome it was it roll I said it
was Jerome or Douglas I said Oh or okay
I didn't know which one it was but they
had to do the process to become a
Spartan twice Wow
so you know they've knowed it the first
time but they did it a second time
there's still full-blown Spartans but
they had to do do not keep him my
children who Locke is right you got to
keep that in mind to them outdated armor
on a smaller we can't minimize
[Music]
three of them like they were nothing is
he at Douglas in his hand and he had him
up in the air keep him keep him on how
heavy horns on right he had him up in
the air and he was he was squeezing the
life out of him you know story try to
stab his arm
yeah and he just looked at him and
smacked him each axis gonna come to you
gonna beat the breaks off of Johnson
yeah did the demon gonna get smoked like
a cigarette and you know they're gonna
take him back his suit them being tad is
gonna give a little soup and hit my spot
a lot going on beat um eight yards back
now the angle beat them because they're
gonna need him you know for the next
game alright but they're gonna they I
mean they gonna beat him back he's gonna
retreat you know gonna be first time and
people won't feel real good about this
sub like we made him retreat oh I see
Calvin right in this story
hoho there's it's not game day years
like say this right I for me in order to
make that story really resonate you have
chief run in there and run slipshod
that's what I was because I think one of
those things where he comes across a
tree arcs in a shots gonna give him that
out to be video I'm not that out I want
man seem to die in it but I just feel
he's so invincible like I don't connect
you know so I think if he had it my god
excited me to just do is meet up without
knowing ya dis say that Jerome enum it
was the old version smart and they had
also I mean there's like the thing is
where he got her jaw had the most
powerful version yeah but listen [ __ ]
I'm telling you what's gonna happen just
like the karate movies we used to watch
on Saturday you're gonna get your butt
beat in the beginning and you know that
then the boss will be welcome at the
last half an hour to film you will fall
Voltron the floods back we don't know
what's gonna happen with the flood
because in the last expansion to Halo
Wars to a tree arcs is to in command
like they're taught people they let him
out
they let the flood out of High Charity
would you like the flow you'll be out of
control sir what it is is a tree arcs
told them to secure High Charity but
don't go in right oh well one of his
brutes one of his commanders is it you
know he I want to say smart but I can't
yeah he he is very arrogant and he want
he's one of those people he's like I
want the shine on me yeah okay and then
at the end of that expansion a tree arc
shows up and he's walking through all
these dead flood mm-hmm and he's like I
told you not to go on for good reason
and then
like what are the floor tries to attach
himself to a charts his head he just
grabs it in midair doesn't even look at
it scorches
well he stopping the flood he has no he
doesn't care about the flood like he is
no like when I tell you this dude is a
problem Wow a ton like I got the grave
oh hello was 2 DLC okay he made me he
talked it up so much I'm like I sure did
the game and I'm playing again I said
just do crazy okay he gotta be over
there girlfriend is he he's what the
Master Chief needed yes yeah Master
Chief has never fought anyone this
dolmen
he needed his Joker like the arbiter you
know Swift stuff became part as friends
and Locke was the fake out okay okay
let's bring solve you got you finish
your boss if I get the PD I mean I mean
let me get these daddy which have Marvel
games the definitely looks good good and
a she whole face don't look too tight
you see the you see this tweet that
showed the number of letters words and
sentences a it the halo message it's a
SS 54 3 or something like that so I
think the exact number of letters in the
message was 3 for 3 so that's cool cool
then we got Jonathan B hold up it jump
me H artist I know some 50 cent mixed
together you see my hands leaving boys
man King do we do till I see we jet
Jheri curls on the Jerome's home it is
extra all we got Cyrus now man we got
Cyrus Burke with the photos we shot a
tree ox is pretty much more lethal than
a squad of Spartan two's his military
might is roughly the second biggest
threat in the galaxy under the flood and
I think the reason he's this dominant is
because he's done all these suicide
missions
he's used
doing this by himself no I don't think
he's ever fought a Spartan till halo
wars 2 because he won't have said that
statement just as I thought he's just a
man
mmm like but he's fought so many people
that he's just like yo these spores they
not in the meaning I'm like doing this
is Soundwave so we got what we got
Jarrell Marisa last one yeah no mocha
smiley with the $10 hoop attack been
watching YouTube shows regarding the
beta for obsidians grounded seeing views
well over a hundred thousand on a couple
of channels the host definitely appear
to be enjoying it crossed another
obsidian as much as I hate to say yeah
yeah I saw yeah I'm told me he looked at
the calendar and said I thought today
was the 28th daddy and his ground it
comes out you know it should be
downloadable right now me but base
definitely for a lot of people a lot of
people love it continue and we have the
ashen Luka drops in support for the
lords and Kings thank you so much Lucca
that seems the homie that's the whole
then we got a we got a tip out super
trap from Cyrus Bert Park man you you
guys can go in there you could clown on
me from our pronunciation skills that
it's like no problem
red team drone Douglas at Allis or
Spartan 2zs Spartan Tuesday I thought
for some reason I thought you say
something else they were initially
washouts like I said they had to do it
twice but then later revived for combat
and Master Chief isn't the most lethal
Spartan that's either Linda or Fred all
right Linda Fred and I'm pretty sure
both of the run-of-the-mill names both
in Master Chief's what's funny is I can
see a world where like for Spartans are
fighting just just a trio well I think
what you gotta do is give its part and
suit the AB you sealant
clutch man with the $2 which at Rome be
Rome and Doug DLC we have rangy for
welcome to the Rome brother we are here
trying to check for that nipple I hear
you Olo and then I got jumped again then
we have our brother once again went away
dragons TV with the file off so the chat
for Avengers endgame to be great the
Avengers had to lose an infinity war
they prepared for the real greatness
this holiday season on the show is lit
thank you brother that is for sure your
heroes have to take five big else
exactly then we have Mariano claw with
the photo switch at hey lords wanted to
ask what you guys think on this whole
possibility of Halo Infinite going
third-person like God award loving the
podcast it's going to be fibers of the
game that's going to take on a different
nature and it's because of certain
reasons inside information cakes clothes
okay so I can dance around as much as
I'm gonna dance around it just dance
around it as good as I did okay right
just gave you information that you
already knew but I'm telling you and how
you read it would you read it like out
of context and yeah you know I wouldn't
mind seeing different aspects of it just
just like part that like a car yeah I
don't want the whole game like that like
there III don't my third party if it's a
part that makes six white needs to be
the third you okay sauce
then we have shroom king to to Lhasa
Pichette Jheri curls under 0 ng helmet
is extra armor I can't remember how
heavy a Spartan armor is keep going we
got looking forward to King's lilyc we
about Phil's interview I'm sure he has a
lot of mind that a triage picked up
Douglass like he like you like he was a
thing of bread the sparked the the
average Spartan armor weighs about a
thousand pounds Jesus continued
we have the dars night potage you know
the five pounds to protect good evening
Lord solo in salute to hanky dinky dodge
and then we have all known a second I
got jumped and then we have pixel busy
with the tight analysis which at brew
top bigger stronger and faster than any
Spartan in the books they have chief
took and this guy is badder and smaller
than most brutes including Tartarus from
Halo 2 so we call we all caught up there
right yeah cool so I'm gonna sleep to PD
I don't know how much I know if he's
front like me with a halo alone hello
but where you at with this did you see
the teaser any thoughts or honestly I
saw the teaser and I'm kind of like you
I'm not totally in tuned to the whole
Halo franchise as Alex would be and and
the others but um I agree with what you
guys are saying that he's gonna in the
beginning he's gonna have to take you
the L and then he you know everyone's
gonna feel bad for him and then
eventually he's gonna he's gonna come
back he's gonna you know he's gonna get
his team together or you know he might
have to go out and recruit some more
Spartans or help them defeat him so you
have all these other possibilities that
might end up happening but to be honest
with you I see a world where a tree ox
joins the flood like like he has to team
up with them because what a lot of
people keep forgetting is Cortana still
lose I was just about to ash but they're
gonna address Cortana in some more it's
in the last game was a lot going after
hunt and chief now this crazy threat is
gonna force these dudes to team up
together so you can see chief side of it
and you don't think or toggle meeting
this game at all yeah I believe what the
katana is gonna be in the game I just
don't believe it's going to play that
big of a part the major focus yeah she's
going to be that overarching like
presence but the direct threat mm-hmm
put a tree arcs out their first quarter
blows to the street everybody's all
riled up because a tree arts right now
mm-hmm
yeah I've never seen hype like this is
kinda crazy kind of crazy dudes is like
they just sent out a voicemail he didn't
like me out of control
I smell any thinking who are they
talking to but the remedy he's supposed
to be trying to fire up the arm the
Halos but that's that's my point but you
know obviously cuz that's how a trucks
in there because they refer to a tree
auxes our savior etc etc I don't know
exact the words they said so I think
it's probably the people who release the
flood in the Panda or whatever his name
is
you know I can't pronounce him
definitely not sure pronounce the names
but you know part of me thinks that you
know the way they're talking
he has teamed up with someone and
they're talking to them your team yeah I
mean like the way team is out and they
leaving a voicemail boom you know biggie
quick as I get I was just curious about
what you guys felt about actually I
heard it
obviously solute addict for put me on
two Halen was to I was introduced to
eight sharks I thought it was the
coolest character going great intro and
I like that they're doing that kind of
like what gears tactics did you do
certain things into the universe and I'm
like okay and now let's go and play out
so I think it's dope I still want to
know where Cortana fits in this I want
to know what a tree arcs his
relationship with Cortana I mean are
they gonna be diametrically opposed that
kind of thing and then um part of me
feels like mm-hmm
he a tree ox is a realist like he takes
on situations because he knows he need
more he he's way better at situations
that he knows he can do stuff better
than a lot of people but to me his
persona is one of those that's like if I
can't handle it I'm gonna I'm gonna team
up with someone that lets me handle it
okay
so team up Tucker the Bobby I given me
like he is old boss like he's you know
he is his own boss but the way he you
know he did team up with the shipmaster
[ __ ] masters a mercenary okay so you
know if he can't handle a situation he
does reach out to people okay but what
about don't don't Cortana got the the
guardians and all that that's what I'm
saying that's the reason she got a lot
of the job in no world in no world do I
think that
in no world do I think they normally
team up with the flood that the flood or
aatrox would would work together
but we can't be acting like Cortana
don't have what like you she's got she's
got guardians that can literally petrow
an entire galaxy by themselves so I
think it will get to the point where the
flood knows they can't take out Cortana
aatrox knows he can't take on courts
alone and then there's a world where
everyone's happy with evil again maybe
she's the boss boss you'll see everybody
got a video of edges infinity who is
still alive but no one has seen him
since the book this is the redemption
but for some weird reason people acting
like five was garbage I love five Aloha
and it's sold well so numbers in the
school playing you know five is doing
its numbers oh like a billion stuff
there we go you know millions millions
on the sub but I believe that this is
going to fix it for a lot of people
really want
[Music]
howdy got him introduced and you know
what King I'm on their side
I play games all right and I don't sit
there trying to tell a better story than
three four three mmm so if I did I will
go get a degree in a so the moment you
put your back behind your word oh and
actually take note you do that
it's on MB watch your knees and your
scripted before stop being backseat
riders listen on brother and it was a
little story there so shine and when I
saw his face I'm like oh you can say
whatever y'all want your backseat
drivers move on to the next as opposed
to the greatest game of mate okay the
banished covenant he says it was like an
hour of don't make us do this we don't
want those people pull up with the
chanclas in the quarter honor rules the
universe but she's logical she didn't
take over for no reason she knows a
bigger threat is coming the flood
returns yes mmm
and we had Gerald Mac go to a super chat
set up to Cognito for boomsticks and
a little URI that's my bro that's my
brother brother from another mother
what else do we have pixel bit again
Subash at halo 5 was decent stop hate
and save lock start infinite murdering
lock that's need to do Wow
let's not forget they were throwing that
halo 5 boss around like trolls and God
of War savage guy BOTS broke sovereign
bro King I'm always on your square but
come on when will they announce halo 5
from Master Chief collection we have our
brother one away dragons TV with the
file a super chat hallo only can be
compared to itself it's a five billion
dollar franchise and five broke all
previous halo numbers because he just so
I like that we all could've been it
looked it looked amazing everybody's
height we just hope we know how
important this halo is and just start it
off with something like this is a good
sign and we just hope this thing
continues but we got all Deebo get them
with the $15 if it's that no need to
explain King I got trolls for liking the
story in the Last of Us
look man we gotta talk about what's
going on in the cyberpunk streets
what's going on city why yeah Manny this
is another one the super truck real
quick yeah it has to do with hey look
okay Forte a homie we go from gaming
Forte hello my story would have been
great if they didn't promote chief
verses law yeah we know they did the
story a disservice that's right what's
my main beef that is completely we got
340 people definitely that like but
let's try to get that above three
eighties this is my truck and overall um
like territory yeah we have to tweet
honey mall you know what you do know how
it goes for the 300 likes the next the
next 300 like mark will be something
that's all of us was going on Soph man
so they had their first episode of night
city wire showing you gameplay and a new
trailer for cyberpunk 2077 which as you
know has been pushed back to November
19th
so um man it's just really excited to be
honest man cyberpunk to me from the
moment they announced this game you know
damn near decade ago or eight years ago
my thing with cyberpunk has always been
how do they incorporate the rules of
cyberpunk into this game or is it just
gonna be another Deus Ex sort of copycat
hmm
and everything that I've seen so far off
the game including what they sort of
touched upon in this first night city
wire indicates to me that they're trying
to make this as immersive an experience
as possible if you look at what they did
with The Witcher 3 and sort of giving
you density of story and an ik and an
expansive world it seems like in this
game they're going
even further with that making the world
even more dense making your your um your
decisions matter it just seems kind of
bonkers that they're really going
forward and I think they might hit it so
what they did here they showed a brand
new trailer with some gameplay um they
announced edge runners which is gonna be
a Netflix anime lol they go really
they're really trying to push a
cyberpunk on you know on different
fronts and I'm happy about that because
Mike Pond Smith needs to get that shine
like a king gonna need all the help he
can get
so the things that stood out to me from
what they talked about during this first
episode night city wire and we're gonna
get I think three or four of them um
they showed a little bit more of the
body modification right body
modification is another one of those
things it's sort of like a tentpole of
cyberpunk um and it seems that you can
really do a lot in terms of how you play
the game and I think that's one of the
things that worried me the most are you
really going to be able to modify
yourself and in turn modify your
gameplay experience so you can
legitimately play the game fully
stealthily along on action hold on
straight up are Pete's like how can you
manipulate the gameplay experience to
have as varied a gameplay experience as
possible and that was something that I
was always worried about with this game
like can they really incorporate the
rules of size and have it be a habit
work um so what I've seen so far is very
interesting now it's like a big thing
that I saw that kind of blew me away in
terms of the depth is the brain dancing
rain dancing is if you've played arkham
origins if you've played any other
batman games and you've seen detective
vision orchid or i believe arkham
origins did it best where it allows you
to see a scenario from from different
perspectives and in turn find clues that
if you know the batman game just gives
you clues to who did who did it right in
this scenario you have the main
character jumping into other people's
bodies experiencing scenarios and then
being able to
into the scenario brain was literally
walk around in the memory and see
different aspects of it which in turn
which I hope this is what they're gonna
do allow you to find little details
about the world the Lord the story
maybe interactions with somebody that
that that was in that particular
scenario that maybe you meet later on in
the game and then based on the whatever
sheisty this you saw them do in that
scenario you know how to deal with them
like there's a number of different
things you can do with this brain
dancing that to me takes that let once
again the rules of cyberpunk
and and being plugged into everything
how are you able to to show that in a
game and this to take that to another
depth and I'm super excited
the only things I'm nervous about what
this game is is the tone in terms of the
speaking options and just acting because
it it can be a little hokey right it can
be a little cheesy because it this this
this super like stylized world and you
know if you look at the Witcher Witcher
had comedic moments but the Witcher
generally pretty seriously right mm-hmm
so this is a game that I'm assuming
because it seems like it's gonna be so
dense you will have Story aspects of the
story and arcs in the story that are
more serious than others but the general
tone feels like an 80s cheesy movie like
it even like you look like like a Fifth
Element or something like that or you
know like a Total Recall stuff like that
and so it's gonna be interesting to see
how they balance that and try to make
everybody happy serious story if they
want a lighter tone story or if all of
that is just in there and they just
allow you to follow whatever path that
you that you want so Dax to me be honest
man like we talked about this at e3 last
year yeah I was super excited by by what
you saw and what we talked about and to
me I was just worried that they could
pull it off right and as we see more and
more it seems like they're gonna pull it
all today that's exciting for you guys
to let me get our PDM because um I don't
know we get a chance cyberpunk would you
at all no no
I've been kind of akin to keeping uh
like watching all the press things and
I've been kind of keeping stuff going on
but there's a couple things like
cyberpunk that kind of makes me like
kind of question cyberpunk like are like
you were saying sod like is it gonna be
a linear game like or it's gonna be like
The Witcher where we can go anywhere at
any time
right like that was one thing and then
the other was just like with the whole
thing with the brainwashing that we saw
up you know instantly clicked on my head
when I started seeing that watch dogs
watch dogs in the brainwashing is like
watch dog is real-time when it's
happening in the game right then both
brainwashing is you can go into the past
and see what's happening all right you
see it from different perspectives
so it kind of made me think like like
like you were saying where is this gonna
take place where is it gonna happen is
we're gonna tell you hey this is what
happens with this individual are we
gonna use it for a boss later on I
thought that was really really cool how
they ended up doing that so then we have
to know what King took this morning
because he is all over the place King is
gonna have a that tier has officially
been removed you totally turn it off yes
it's gone wait wait which one did the
top one it was another one there was
$4,000 no no no that wasn't a now that
was the hog I don't know yeah that's
also will be still out here these
I for one recommend a horn tat hashtag
reparation is the water way drag is once
again with the funnel superjet 300 likes
means addict has to shave that Grizzly
Adams that's not a like ratio that's
gonna that's gonna have to be a cash
[Laughter]
that's gonna be out of control
just put the trucker hat on
then we have the final super chat
totally agree with Lord sob cyberpunk is
gonna is the real deal cyberpunk gonna
have the streets we got eternal a super
chef from cat-daddy cyberpunk is one
going hard with my PC bill I can't wait
for you to do such a big cat daddy you
know why you build up we'll talk of
liability a chat cyberpunk 2077 fury
edition then we have Dan rod he'd
literally waited for his cause he was
like whole crash in that chair welcome
to absolute the season game and a big
cast by Bros Bert it's great guys great
podcast great website we had a bond last
week hilarious episode salute to those
dudes man good good good podcast you
they show yeah I think we got to work
with AIDS and do some work on Sam are
you working on some that's what salute
what else we got so we have scrub nurse
with the $10 to protect glad I caught
you guys live - points
77 all I need now is a 20-sided die and
I'm in yeah baby tabletop game with Mike
P and CD Projekt up for trying this yeah
I mean to move max Mike consummate this
this this love is long overdue all over
though it's a low salute
with the trucks all I want to do is talk
to Judy inside 77s relax yourself sir
relax yourself
yeah well caught up shout out to boogie
and Eliot slow move it you made of make
comments specifically about with this
interesting but I don't think it applies
mom Eliot said I will will this game get
overlooked for game of the year because
it comes out so late now and I think it
still makes the cut actually well
actually it doesn't technically right
now really but what's funny is Keeley
said yo boys Flint they my is out
because because when that happened
though oh it's it's a November really
like we could now we could put that Jeff
q was like nah that ain't happened yet
jokingly said they looking into making
exceptions to the rule based on what had
happened I believe would a Jedi fall in
order last year cuz I think that's gonna
come up again this year because it's
probably gonna make one thing that's all
I his boy is not on deck this year when
his boy was on the real game real quick
so up I don't know how you caught idiot
at alone in a city why not
because me King have there's been the
knee going on with Cyrus I am Boyka
Boyka
when it comes to cyber pot it I'm a huge
fan of the the next man I always
mispronounced that name other the Duke
sex or whatever oh yeah the XX I'm a
huge fan of that franchise and this
looks like that on steroids so I'm
definitely going to be there day one
it's okay man they're gonna need a lot
more than my one copy to make you here
we go let's take the game plays out
gonna have those conditional knees
that's fine
but we missed up so we have jobs and B
with the funnel super 10 I'm tired of it
I'm officially leading an uprising the
old Lords need our horns be a smart
delivery ASAP look next weekend we'll
make sure next week because I do
understand you know some people are
upset we will make sure to we had that
horns and I will personally go through
and read the first couple people that
didn't get the horns I will give you
your horn let me back up at once new
cyberpunk release Dave falls in the
launch window for Xbox series X could
this be a game that gets bundled to new
console like like all this was crazy
Oh Jews knew I was onto something from
day one but y'all didn't wanna listen
y'all crazy
what you got delayed I go for it we did
lay out the PlayStation Show and I told
you what day was like oh boy I was like
King they said the fourth
and what happened wait Gerald Mac with
the file a super chat cyberpunk 2077
looks like it will have the same level
of detail as Red Dead Redemption - I'm
sure you'll be able to see the seven
years of development yeah you know I'll
tell you this like what I'm looking
forward to in next gen isn't like don't
give me don't give me a world that's
like twice the size of GTA v like give
me a world that that it's that size or
smaller but I can go into every build
that's impressive to me Robert I want
density I want density you can't do that
okay you're not going in every building
oh yeah y'all think so here yeah but I
mean work towards that I get it yeah the
next consoles none with these current
gen D so there we have cat daddy put the
crust in the chat upgraded his
membership thank you lord I guess it
didn't come up the members try to do
unique ways to get you vision
what do I get home crazy that would work
people originally they were doing it so
people probably in that chat just
waiting for someone to try it you'll cut
up I just got a shout out to Tommy were
saying cyber bush 20 because I felt that
the game is going to be fantastic I saw
like Deus Ex that's what it reminds me
of when I get the game I'm gonna have
fun with it I expect it to be inside
game pass day and date of release
bundled with the series X and a la carte
so everybody
game past you'll have a smile on its
holiday season while you play your games
and if you have listened Microsoft has a
console for you if you have a teal TCL
you know if you can't make the leap
don't worry about it they got you your
pockets as care you know the lockhardt
you hear the latest rumor on the
Lockhart yeah that the clocks the clock
speeds are the same as series X so GPU
down that's fire
let me wait let me get it to it man home
yeah for me you know I got shafted my
boy for it takes we was good at it it uh
that's good he would just like was
chance and I get it you know the thing
for him is his issue was that it went on
too long as far as the brain dance thing
but guys like me I love that kind of
stuff so I love the Detective aspect
putting a piece of the mystery together
it also it also gave me a little bit
Detroit became human vibes of Rio
creating a crime scene I love that kind
of stuff I love it man so for me I'm
like just watching the replay err to see
him the angles and they come to find out
that to do that went to go put the
contract and the work in he ended up
getting Merc by his amazed at the end
when you need the footage so I just
think that stuff was pretty cool if
you're into like um like I'm the guy
that watches those forensic shows you
know and they simulate how to win a
bully cave from it like so that's me now
I'm all that you know I want to shout
about bro
Lord J Fonzarelli you're not supporting
the grounded game if got cyberpunk
forgot you get over there by boy J
Fonzarelli he's got it rocking with the
grounded gamer channel he's got a ton of
cyberpunk videos so Lulu but uh good to
put it in terms he's covering
cyberpunk more than we cover destiny
yeah yeah he's in his bag so salute that
I think the Ripper docks thing is cool
for the augments I like that aspect song
I think that's dope and I liked where
they showed the badlands they showed the
Bailey's he was going outside to see
like some Mad Max vibe get in it
it reminded me of Rage a little bit
we're not happy about that but
I'm ready I'm high on this whole
situation a man listen this is the
giveaway let's get right to it
so big big news this week max off
clothes mixer service 20-second plans
the move existing partners over to
Facebook gaming surprise announcement
means that mixer partners fix your face
PD mixer partners mystery ICU victim for
the streams will be transitioning the
Facebook gaming and Microsoft will no
longer operate max mixer as a service in
a month's time so feel fulfilled ominous
came out he said oh we started pretty
far behind in terms of where mixes
monthly active viewers were compared to
some of the big players out there and
then he pretty much said that um he
thinks the mix of communities gonna
benefit from the broader off
audience that Facebook has and then
pretty much they said that they're gonna
partner with them existing mixer viewers
and streamers or with a facebook gaming
in the coming weeks on July 22nd though
all mixer sites and apps will
automatically redirect to Facebook game
fix your face PD and mix it so just
thank you you you dancin to the grave
right now fix your face miksa viewers
without stain just oh are you going
first for this my balance and mixer
proscription now in conjunction with
this news we got all my stores y'all
like so stores they given up physical
retail so I'm there the out of there the
company plans to announce our permanent
close of all microsoft store locations
so on yeah it looks like they're just
gonna be reimagined and a company shot
to the verge with this article they said
that um no layoffs though no layoffs
will result from the decision they said
on commitment to growing and development
careers from this divert talent pool is
stronger than ever so for my
understanding that um this was something
that was in plan already for next year
for them to close them down and that it
was accelerated by the you know to cover
a pandemic so look big news let's start
with mixer and if you want to include
Microsoft stores you could do that as
well but P we at the stream team is what
platform we should stream to we ended up
stream into all platforms but PT I know
you're very passionate about this what
was what was your thought process where
the news came down mixer is um closing
business
I bet usually look more crisp while
mixer though so a couple of things
before before I start doing my whole
rant of what's that well what's going on
I was you know when you hear something
like this happen and the whole streaming
realm of things you're you kind of you
feel devastated at the same time because
a lot of these people that's where
they're making their money that's what
they're making their living so it's like
pretty much a whole tire company
shutting down so you have people that
that's what they depend on for their you
know their income so I felt like really
really bad and like I felt really I
I felt like this was like not something
I wanted to happen because yeah those
are people making their livings though
that's their that's their livelihood
facts um so I mean I wasn't happy to
hear that as she wasn't happy to hear
about people getting you know laid off
let's not be real here you smile let's
go switch I look at this smile
I've said it all that's all the times
before and I'll say it again when it
comes down to it the analytics was not
there right for longevity analyst wasn't
there when they decided hey we're gonna
bring ninja on Rogue River and shroud on
we're gonna bring kid and get that only
on and I said it back then you did
if you end up bringing these people on
they're only gonna watch those people
and then bounce if they're even going to
stay and everyone's like oh look at all
the you know the free subs they're
getting they're starting oh look at all
this I'm like it's kiss you guys are
giving them free subs they're gone after
that month and that's essentially what
happened and throughout the course of
the of this week when we heard I looked
at Facebook gaming and the same thing
[Music]
that will work for you because people
like to admire what's around you I know
oh yeah mine is blurry because you don't
want to see this back in I would like
you to blur that creepy Mario though no
I put them in for you but you gotta put
him peeking behind they beamed adequate
Vario with the curtain
you see all the way back there in a
washing machine yeah I'm gonna stick his
head in every week and we we put him a
little bit beauty finish that when we
gotta catch up so you know I went on
like I'm saying I went on to Facebook
aiming and I looked at it and you know
people are saying although there's
growth there there's growth there yeah
because if you take your stuff and you
just post on your Facebook wall people
are just gonna be scrolling through the
facebook wall and they're gonna see it
so you're gonna have instant growth that
way but you're not gonna actually have
viewership there's a difference between
having viewership and growth and there's
a difference between people actually
returning and people actually watching
it you have multiple different things
that you actually have to look at and
for them to like I think it was um I
think it was a gaming forte that we were
talking to you about this and he said I
don't want to be sitting on my Facebook
and having my grandma or my aunt coming
into my facebook game I'll play my luck
making a comment you know that's the
truth I I think that like a lot of these
guys that ended up leaving would
actually benefit from either a go into
YouTube or be going to twitch now
there's a rumor going on right now you
see there which which one there's two
[Music]
talking about starting their own brand
just because because because concept
that's me this morning and I said they
could do it they have like 50 million
dollars between the three of them so I
mean they could essentially build their
own platform if they really wanted to
the money that would help them is the
relationship with the content creators
on all the other platforms that what
they won't do it I would I would be
there with you King but the fact that
none of these men have addressed
anything they haven't sent where they're
going they haven't put anything on there
no alien is going to fit like a week
without his different colors
six million dollars they hadn't said
where they're going but at it six
million dollars do you need to work
again if you have twenty six million
dollars yes you do the money only want
one thing and that's more money but an
addict they have to he's I'm pretty sure
he sent his lawyers to go through that
contract because like we said I don't
want to jump out of turn do you think
yeah let Peter get but my theory is on
you BAE some great points actually does
he agrees with a lot of the points you
say yeah um I guess my question is in
reference to like you said we talked we
got those three that you know for the
most part the prominent for what I was
told the prominent guys were informed
they knew this was coming but the sad
reality is there's a ton of mixer
streamers who did not and it was very
emotional some people you know cry no
siree and they they had no idea now that
sets up twitch kinda I guess to kind of
come in and I've seen some scenarios
where I guess twitches allow some people
who maybe have had issues before to come
over so what do you think in reference
to like just just twitch just benefit
now with that do you think Facebook game
even has a chance based on what you're
saying but no people don't like the
privacy or the personal information
aspect with business on Facebook gaming
so from the big was what I like to call
the corner quote the victory of of mixer
those over there I mean they they
literally could whatever they want and
then they don't have any problems but I
think that all of these smaller
streamers that do you did you start off
your joint with a caveat what did you
know that you actually you know twitch
PD is compromised if you actually
your statements is not unbiased that you
have everybody knows his partnership is
cloudy for viewers that are viewing that
don't know is enough switch affiliate
it's now the hungry
so um let's let the proceed know how you
would like that okay okay that's fine
you did me like that with platinum gay
that's foul listen I tell dudes ahead of
time very early so we compromise these
numbers and stuff like that and he's
giving you no real Brooksie being it I'm
not stream really goes after he tells
you good until you feed it we gotta get
banks could do it so you maybe lose my
train of thought
mission accom saying like oh these guys
the big guys can do whatever they want
the now about two and a half three years
ago mixer and Facebook gaming they ended
up going into the the twitch community
and actually looking at partnered twitch
streamers between having viewers of 150
to 300 people and go into them and going
hey what you doing were having we're
producing this Cutlass console you guys
come over we'll pay you will give you
the bag well you guys can come over I
got a combination on that from very
close people yes so a lot of people have
done that so now all these people that
moved over there are now like alright
well what are we gonna do are we gonna
go back or we not and they're gonna go
more than likely they're gonna go back
there's also been little rumbles um in
the underground talking about 10 cent
who has their streaming platform over in
Europe and its European locked so
don't they don't have any type of
presence in the u.s. to possibly even
opening up something in like you know
the US area to allow a new streaming
platform here I don't know how that
would even work or how that would be
but that's something else that I've
heard underneath the table that's been
going through so you have multiple
things that are happening so let's get
let's get actually before we start let
me solve I know we got let's catch up to
super chair was someone joint around we
got to respect that
okay it's your boy Matt EP witnesses
please say something brother thank you
so much the place for Kay to build a
nanny baby yourself Luke baby once I got
that okay we got Luke lure with the 2000
set she's just um xep and then we have
regulator welcome to the round round
daughter Chris awful regulated oh yes
hello
he had his horns so no then we have
gamers play with the $10 that gamers
play you got to get at me DM me I owe
you something yes game is play you one
come on man get your winnings man yes
sir the move to drop mixer is a smart
one although the fact they dropped
without warning is sad for creators made
a living at which to the rescue hand and
our partnerships like pamphlets I had
one other thing I wanted to say okay
then we have a Rodimus with the final
super cat Mario will be addicts Elf on
the Shelf sexy naughty naughty or nice
you know what that makes me want to do
man you know what that makes me want to
do pyaza
TARDIS camera continue seeing this
continue then we have regulator with the
photo ops over chat hey lords can you
guys give a shout-out to my son he's a
hardcore minecraft gamer
yes minecraft on every platform his
gamertag is lbm 951 that's what if you
have 951 my son is playing Minecraft
right now I'm pretty sure you're
building worlds to govern oh yeah yo Sal
old man lo little big man now 5-1 that's
what so regulated so what stood out to a
door black magics
um Killa cam wonder shot him out man yes
that's our guy back Cory hi guys
understand that his father is part of
the realm yes does big things as part of
IOP respect you are a no so look back
Petey get your balls off there we gotta
go to bed so the other thing I was gonna
say was um with everything with the hate
going on in the streaming world like if
you if anyone has any type of like ear
to any of the streaming stuff that's
going on with all the hate that's been
going on I'm just gonna call it in
general hate for everything that's going
on because there's just so much going on
I'm not gonna sit here and say X Y & Z
so with all the hate that's been going
on on the mixer platforms like and and
that pretty much absorbed like you know
destroyed them all the heat that's been
going on online with all of that yeah
and on top of that there's a lot of hate
that's also been sliding through
everything on Twitch right and I think
this is the first time that twitch has
actually seen this all happening and
they're just swinging the bat they're
just knocking people out left or right
now if anyone has heard in the past I
think it was like 36 48 hours and the
whole thing with doctor disrespect with
that whole thing now we don't know
what's going on we don't know the
specifics they haven't really spoken
about it but people are saying it's a
big deal and I don't know what it is
specifically but for other streamers to
come out and say yeah we know what it is
and it's a big deal it means that people
are now saying no more to this right
this is bull and we're gonna go through
it and I think that's something else
because I've also seen a couple of close
partner streamers that I speak to right
and that they've actually said that
they've had confrontations with people
twitch staff that are like actually in
control of the partnership path the
hands passive partnership that that's
that was really really intense like
people of like sexually harassing other
people like you do this I will give you
this if you do this you will that's not
flying anymore
and that's something that I will say
should never have been flying period
right for any platform whatsoever
and to see now unfortunately with
everything that has kind of occurred
because of mixer do you see other
platforms not only twitch but like
Facebook YouTube a lot of a lot of them
are now just swinging the bat banning
people permabanning people permabanning
IPS yeah from people's houses so I think
that it's an unfortunate thing that we
even have to discuss this yeah but it's
a it's the unfortunate thing with mixer
shutting down it is is kind of gotten
the ball rolling to make the world a
little bit of a better place which is of
do got one question for you Lauren oh
the in the sense of I mean now can we
just say nah I mean obviously Facebook
game it exists right but for the most
part outside of Italian it doesn't seem
to be well-received so maybe it does
this create a situation when it almost
like a monopoly like yeah yeah that's
like that's pretty much what's ending up
happening and you know the it's turning
into a monopoly for twitch and Amazon is
just sitting there stomping their feet
all over everybody else know what you're
talking about
[Music]
we got lower beds that are building
actually man now with just the egg on
the logo what's going on so be eggs in a
building what would you feel man mixer
what's going on what you feel well
listen firstly before King comes for
monies and lows of that parlor I am also
a Twitter Fillion okay without the door
thank you so much for walking in the
door and showing your badge
don't be surprised me as if we asked
your kind to get on the left to the side
people left another make sure people
just stay out the club a document former
mixer people honestly you better put a
gas mask on because it's gonna be a lot
of smoke cover with you go I got it we
got but we got beds guy gets puzzle um
all right so full disclosure like I said
I am Twitter Philly but also shout-out
to Dustin Poirier amazing fight last
yeah so I actually was one of those
folks who like if you don't know I'm the
mixer getting general I started this I
you know I was rapping mixer gang heavy
and for several reasons one bring it in
I had become disenchanted with twitch at
a certain point in time around that time
because many people on twitch were
getting away with things that they
shouldn't have been getting away with
for a long time women showing you know
yeah it's animal abuse all these kind of
things things that are not acceptable
and they should have been reprimanded
for but we're not and at the same time
mixture came through the moon into the
bag it came it created a little bit of a
buzz and not only that but I that made
me go to mixer and say wow this act this
quality is actually yes weight better
than Twitter old way baby see but it was
the platform continued Katti batti
no not dizzy dizzy and cog he already
waived his wife legs oh no you think
it's a fish Cargill ice well let you
know your man the CEO Lords gaming said
to me to me you use you your patty
anyway continue like the platform itself
I never felt was the issue because I
felt the platform in terms of its
quality was beyond all the others
it was always the problem of the
viewership yes and I had a lot of fun
streaming over there I make sure they
had a lot of cool features that twitch
ended up stealing by the way and and
then it there came a time where um there
was a report where I believe you guys
discussed it here on this podcast where
morale at mixer was low yeah something
like that yes and there was a video
leaked of an internal meeting that they
had with the staff where there's new CEO
lady was brought in and she was like
really condescending to the staff and
her entire attitude it turned me off
completely to the Mixter platform and
when I saw that video I said this
thing's got six months left of life in
it max yeah it was it was a spooky for
when we went to pax their section until
we were hear rumblings - oh yeah
continue there was there was no mixer
presence but gaming presence or twitch
presence and your boy that was huge yeah
and did your before will afford it were
there facts yeah so when I saw that
video that video right there made me
pack my bags and ditch the mixer gang
and I said you know many other people
you know thank you for having me but
wait wait I did you did when did you
officially feel that after that video
leaked with that lady being
condescending to the employees I was out
I was out because it just felt like the
beginning of the end to me and that's
when I I dipped out and I went to
Twitter and actually I'm not even mad at
twitch like I had a really good
experience on swish I'm not I like
twitch yeah fortunate the quality is not
as good as mixer and the other thing is
is that with them with meds and myself
were both in that Affiliate state which
is actually he pulled you close down so
when the bullets go there's actually
there's actually a thing with us being
that were not partners we don't have the
ability to have all like the frames and
everything like that but once you get
[ __ ] all that unlocks oh they're very
straight partnered and affiliates in
terms of their quality and also if you
ever go on a twitch stream the option
question yeah this is real quick
I'm Jen and I need to I need to make
sure I load my guns properly oh yeah
so in mixer all those things was
afforded to you when you yeah there was
nothing that you'll react as far as I
can remember all right other
monetization was locked behind the
partnership okay all right all right oh
there was no restriction as far as
stream quality and stuff like that yeah
yeah on twitch oh there they put you at
480p you can stream @ 1080p you can't do
4k if you wanted to you just got to be
throttled for a period always you're
thinking if i stream a 1080p on twitch
as of right now you let's say you may be
on your phone and you're on your 4g and
it's not fast enough to keep up with the
1080p you don't have to option of
switches it to 480p so you can keep up
my only stream @ 1080p and i don't have
the ability to swap off unless i log in
so what ends up happening is they have X
amount of slots open free slots and then
you have all your partner slots partners
automatically get all their slots they
can do whatever they want if I log in
and not all the partners use up all the
slots I can slide in and have multiple
different options so you just gotta get
on windows motorsport for sure that's
afforded to you from the platform is
something that if you wake up already
know how to hold up that dead that's
bull like I should be able to turn down
the quality of the 630 so I can get one
of those let me get this straight
you gotta you don't rotate your schedule
around you know when you're at work or
will your people can play you or I take
the scheduler on when when people can
you actually a my turn the quality down
what blows my mind look at 7:00 7:00 to
11:00 every day I scream and I log in at
6:30 to make sure I get one of those
slots beds get its paws off listen this
that that grape is a graph that we all
share everybody hates it in fact I only
stream at 720p because many people hit
me up after I stream and they're like yo
bro I wanted to watch a stream but I
couldn't I was on my phone so I turned
it down from tonight EPA taken game AI
now yeah just to make it more accessible
to more people just let let me get this
straight I always thought that I don't
go over on Twitch at all I am for the
most part i've streamed on there but
it's always been jokes and stuff like
that's not really been you know a
full-time thing you mean to tell me now
you've been streaming it and kappa for
this platform that won't even let you
was teammates he was a cab no I'm
talking about that won't even let you
give the ability to change your quality
for your consumers in the viewership of
your channel I just how meds and pedia
how are you to railroad you I'm not here
to captain makes honestly I'm just here
to pour out the 44 mix it cuz I feel sad
because honestly like did you guys tune
in to make sure that dignity announced
this shattered like I said before even
sort of talking yeah I'm not even happy
for it because people's lives are
destroyed yeah so you know make sure
we're talking about that anti kid super
stoked whatever they own it it don't add
a gate owners that
in in meds this is about twitch
ransoming the ability to change your
quality let's say yo yo yo I know your
fans because I have that issue like I'll
go to watch twitch and I'm like yo why
is it always buffering and I've got I've
always wondered why I can't change the
quality I just figure I'm dumb and I
don't know how to do it on that it's not
because I'm dumb on twitch but it's
become twitch is ransoming that ability
to let you people do that like the
biggest one of the biggest gripes for
twitch is that you cannot change you
can't change that your your your bitrate
your all any of that and I and I say
that all the time mixer had a better
backbone then switched it the only
difference was the analytics right plain
and simple Eddie's we can have the best
things in the world but you can't use
anything you don't have the analytics
you told me that if I want to watch
twitch on my phone I kind of go I gotta
find a me I gotta find a twitch partner
now you gotta be a Wi-Fi so that is
crazy it's also a bad app it's also a
bad app is well this is listen King I
don't stream on Twitch because like I'm
like rah rah twitch look good because
else am I supposed to go bro yeah to go
I'm not streaming on YouTube the
quality's even worse than twitch and the
analytics for getting a streamer on
there it's almost impossible to get some
extra man make sure we needed make sure
we Facebook gaming like PD said it's not
a real competitor they can fall on these
numbers but we all know that Facebook is
they're a bunch of liars like they could
be inflating these numbers in any sorts
of ways like what Pete just said
somebody scrolling down your wall your
timeline or whatever happens to occur
they're not sticking by and watching
your stream
nobody bro nobody watches people on
Facebook it's not there they think there
is a all the numbers they want it's not
true there is people that are embedding
links to their facebook gaming accounts
to their twitch accounts and to their
mixer accounts back one mixer was around
so so people when they're scrolling up
and through it they were getting views
that way mm-hmm because they were being
able to you know con the views oh and
that's essentially what mm-hmm
soft shout I'm gamers play sent you to
DM on that foot all no get real quick so
let's get solve it because I didn't get
your thoughts on this let's give a shout
out to cucumber for joking around with
the $2 which at is Nintendo running
Twitch Nintendo and they backwards self
would let me do that they just want to
give a microphone shut up twitch the
earlybird can get is for a TI on we got
cat daddy with the $2 jet - it's kind of
early and in the 1080p food stamp I
would just downgrade your video 720p man
no I ain't gonna be in 2020 and
streaming stuff at I know I wouldn't
play it at that quality why would why
expect people to watch me play it at
that quality love that just that blows
my mind man you know what you know that
is not my twitch but good I'll be
finished if we caught up yeah we could
all right now get your balls up so I
mean obviously I'm not happy for people
who's in their livelihood but when you
see you people crying on you know on
stream
talking about like you know it kind of
their the entire
we heard their life is kind of over it
goes to show you that more than anything
else people are loyal to the platforms
as opposed to I mean obviously right you
have these big streamers that have their
followings huge followings
but as kind of evidenced by by ninja
when he came over initially the numbers
were right but when everything leveled
out the numbers weren't quite the same
because I think of the day people are
kind of loyal to the platform and not
necessarily as much to the streamer
they're gonna find the delays in a rep
right you mean like they're gonna find
another extreme of the rep so um and
this is the thing that's so this
monopoly that which has it's kind of
bonkers to me like it's it's kind of
impenetrable so when you see mixture
going away obviously everything that's
going on in the world everything that's
been happening on the internet within
the Internet is burning right now like
for mixer to go away right now for other
reasons as well kind of bodes well for
them in that regard they don't have to
address search and certain negativity
that's going on and kind of push it
under the rug and and focus on we're
shutting it down and we're moving it to
its other platforms so beyond just the
the money and the logistics of it
because the thing is when you look at it
when you look at the logistics of it
when you're in a situation where the
vast majority of the world is home and
your numbers don't go up yeah yeah brah
that's a problem that's a problem I mean
so it's real quick before I go to God o
King but I get his balls yeah like is it
just one of those things you just said
look for the numbers we just got a cut
bait it's not working and I yeah I think
I'm sorry that's awful no no I think
that this has been in the works yeah
before since the two three years ago
like I was saying when they were trying
to pull people off a twitch yeah and
they really didn't divulge any of that
information right and I really think
that this has always been in the back
ground that they were gonna do and I
think their decision was to merge mixer
into Facebook gaming and give them their
backbone right and that's what I feel
has always been a thing because they
were always there were always too
buddy-buddy yeah it was really really
awkward it was like two friends hanging
out you're like they're not really
friends they're dating what I mean it's
a good point because I mean they're not
gonna go was Amazon controls twitch I
mean it's it's a good bedfellow to speak
to like you know say it's far in stay
cam is the only place Microsoft could go
if they could and if they're gonna drop
mixer so it makes sense from a
partnership standpoint yeah it's just
that the question remains
you know the Facebook's commitment to it
and then obviously stream is like might
say flattered strippers don't feel
comfortable with face but most people
associate Facebook with their personal
life in it personal business so I don't
like that but people field Facebook is
evil yeah yeah right now Facebook is
daddy especially now like I personally I
take all my all my Instagram and my
Twitter that is and and it's all related
to my twitch right it's like I feel like
that's my quote unquote
business side of my life right Facebook
I literally leave it there to talk over
my friends because you want to see
pictures of my business telling you that
you just acknowledge the fact that
that's your business this is your
business side and this is your other
life not mine
that doesn't matter that's for you
that's your business so let's talk about
the retail aspect of this with the with
the Microsoft Store closing oh we didn't
have a separate thing not okay let's
combine let's combine the Lyle is bad we
give it this attention all this yes okay
so what Phil spots
dominus Spencer talk but could he yeah
retail stuff like like we've been saying
from the beginning of a big Rona yeah
the retail yeah at the fame the retail
markets in the world are gonna be
severely affected from this point on
like ones that link back to what some
semblance of normalcy it's still not
gonna be the same because retail is
gonna be affected from this point on um
and we we've seen that a smaller
companies have talked about how this
situation has forced them to look
a distance work situation and and quite
frankly a lot of them has seen uptick
sin in our finances just because of the
fact that they're not they don't have
overhead of rent they don't know no
electricity
oh it's named for their employees they
don't have to travel so we figured that
the retail scene would be changing from
this point forward what I didn't figure
is that one of the first big companies
to show how that's happening would be
Microsoft yeah if you look at everything
they're talking about in the digital
space and then being a software company
it makes sense but I'm to be honest I I
was kind of shocked just to see it at
them sort of be at the forefront of it
all right my issue of this whole mixture
thing is I was such a no rant about the
twitch thing I didn't get to say
anything about the measure III think
Microsoft like they could have handled
this so much better like it's just like
you literally you you you you literally
pretty much let people out to dry like
and then I saw some some reactions that
like they said like we're partners and
no one toda it's like I think maybe that
like the racial things that was
happening in the corporate level may be
that that ricocheted their timing when
they was gonna tell people but it's like
at that point like you said you don't
shut down until you give your partner's
at least time to learn a little bit
there's enough time to get get out of
the way to Boulder right okay yeah I
don't know the boat are pretty big you
listen you're fired next month
find another job you you know that you
know that that's seen or se before
you're running from the boulder and the
boat is that literally the the butter is
the size of the road that is literally
what's happening now
learn how to dig faster so the thing
that struck me immediately one of the
first things I said what's gonna happen
to the vast majority these retail jobs
right so you know when you mentioned
today that they made a commitment to
keeping all of those people on right it
means that you know this is not like the
housing bubble or like the dot-com
bubble where you don't have a physical
product and you don't have a plan as to
how you're gonna sustain a company
that's just sort of in the ether right
right mm-hmm so the fact that they're
gonna figure out how to place all of
these people that would be working on
stores and he really speaks to the
transformative nature of what's
happening yes so retail like it really
is this is this is an inflection point
that cannot be ignored things are gonna
be different from this point in facts
moving forward in fact yeah do you think
they're gonna start taking people look
cuz like you know you got like Best
Buy's and all those other stores that do
sell Microsoft things in those stores
you think they're just gonna be
Microsoft employees are just gonna be
forced to work in those stores they're
equipped to from the document I've seen
I see like they equipped to work
remotely there they still gonna play to
pay these guys to operate basically
they've been operating in this capacity
since the pandemic anyway because I've
been closing so date for what the
initial statement is what they said
right now we don't know if things can
change
no one's getting laid off that everyone
at work the stores is gonna be working
in an online capacity to where they have
been to this point so this clearly was
preparing but I think because of the
pandemic maybe that transition but King
I gotta get you get your bars off you've
been waiting but chomping you know real
quick what's going on man let me give my
caveat I am NOT a mixer or yes so I'm
coming to you Mario I would like to
first start off with the stores all
right
so um this pandemic has shown companies
that they can save money mmm all right
and it helps the bottom line now when
they say they're not gonna cut jobs
they're not gonna cut high-level jobs
the low-level jobs as far as the stock
boys and stuff like that thing that's
how it's gonna go
um journalist pandemic a lot of uh we
have unemployment's that are hitting
record record numbers yeah okay and I
don't believe that to change anytime
soon until we can pivot into a place
where we can make this marketplace work
for us we have to figure it out right so
those jobs that are going away from the
retail standpoint those are the true
part were you supposed to be like you
know I feel for these guys but it's not
just one company Microsoft since when
and I know and I've tried to think about
this well when did I go and purchase the
surface from the store
most of my stuff like if I purchased
them from a Microsoft Store I'm
purchasing online they ship it to me
anyway right so um I'm pretty sure they
did analytics and said the stores wasn't
as viable as and we thought they were
they didn't become as big as Apple so
boom factor let's go let's get out of
there this is the cleaning up phase guys
consolidation yes
um now as far as mixer everybody can
tell that is a fill or product hmm
so what do you want them to do stick
there and hold down the fort okay right
at one point time did that make sense to
you that you know you know what we got
the best quality but for some reason
nobody's coming over here so you know
what we're gonna do we gonna partner
with somebody that actually show growth
know the people that show the most
growth so I would say yo that is a great
idea now also they said if you are a
mixer or affiliate you were going over
the Facebook mm-hmm okay
so that means your job was secure okay
now it's up to you to grow your job but
I gotta count if you I gotta play fair
kid you know when the graphic is
completely different right right
now this is with the mark know the
partnership comes in with game paths and
x cloud facts now when our Facebook owns
Instagram and what's that right huge
you're looking at a three pronged
approach that Amazon does not have mmm
all right that twitch does not have this
three prong approach can actually affect
you in a ways that when those ads pop up
and you click it your
instantly into X cloud right all right
so that's going to allow Twitter for
mixer affiliates to be seen because when
those gains pop up did I say well your
favorite such-and-such is playing this
game do you want to see how they got
past dis bordick Lee basically the
features that stadia promised yes have
it lived up yet which was yeah to stream
but was supposed to come on you're
supposed to see such a such play and
because the cloud it's supposed to play
their game or whatever I feel you could
to you
so med said that people use their
Facebook and they scroll down mm-hmm
right so while you're scrolling down you
see something that's interesting I say
it all the time I click it right if I
stick around a stick around
yeah all right but you're giving the
boss visibility to everyone how many
people in here have Facebook everybody
right how many people here have twitch
everybody everybody everybody I don't
want which but I can't get on my phone I
told your heart I don't have either oh
right I don't do that anytime I got a
watch mixer is because it's an xbox
showing I'm watching from my xbox when
they forced me to write and I'm being
honest right so now on the Facebook you
scroll down you be like oh no P playing
this game oh okay okay so you
automatically instantly connected to
friends how many your friends actually
watch your twitch I I actually actually
have a question for you yeah yes good
how are you gonna stream from your xbox
when you can't when they don't have the
evaluation aspect to the integration
they listen i'm not i'm not streaming
i'm talking about the deal you talk
about right you talk about for the
ex-client you looking at this this is a
benefit to X cloud because this is their
vision long-term right that's all that
stuff stop when it's tough to make
dollars facebook's is going to start to
make sense
mmm right well what I'm saying to use
how many friends do you have on Facebook
that actually follow you on Twitch
that's a good point it's almost a
separate
I think I feel the Lord started
streaming we lose it restream and we see
the Facebook I've got people that never
touched YouTube never attached to it
there's a whole new audience I'm not
saying it's super big but I will say
this people like oh wow and they're
watching you know the stuff so it is a
different audience and into Kings Point
right we cannot dismiss though as much
as people don't like Facebook and we
know the feelings we can't dismiss the
global reach as far as a platform right
there penetration they have as far as a
plan and you don't Instagram on top of
that so as well whereas the streamer
crowd is probably losing out right
there's not going to be the mixer
integration I mean you have the option
to transition over but you don't
necessarily want to but for X cloud to
have those two sources as platforms to
integrate is pretty huge for their long
term vision what X level there's no
Microsoft mixer as a failed company made
a Power Move to have a bigger reach that
might then mixer would ever have right
so pairing up with Facebook actually
reached everybody that was inside that
room right like everybody that's in this
room Oh
all your friends that don't watch your
twitch right but that's on your Facebook
that I look at what opt put up to oh my
god Peter's playing the game oh this is
my aunt that I haven't spoke to us so
this is a lot of people don't what that
a lot of people don't what they don't
say I'm gonna say something Kings will
actually surprise you which I very much
surprised you and I spoke to bet on
round table with the stream team before
all right
mm-hm so I regularly post a link in my
Facebook page when I first started
streaming hardcore saying hey go and
live blah blah blah come and see me
right I had family
unfriend me oh you could are sitting
here so people will actually see that as
something that's bad and unfriend you
right so it was probably unfriending you
because they couldn't get that stream
mr. you Michael I'm not disagreeing with
you King there and they want to be able
to play and they want to get the
outreach like you're saying so be it all
right big Olympic I don't think so okay
i wreck right
people like to be voyeurs people like to
peek in but you don't want you to tell
them what to do so when they see your
views go up hmm do this in your class
that's hating on you they don't give you
know like make you watch your jointing
you know you know people be looking at
your fool pics but don't put no like but
they know that you ate food that you
reach it officer let me at chaos be the
answer before this is the big I got it
the the question shout the hope law he's
got a tremendous video up right now with
this whole situation but the question is
the money spent
we know they spent so much with ninja
shroud and not a try okay and no point
i'm is winning guaranteed fan out right
so if what was he supposed to say well
you know what twitch is up there and you
know let's not take on that juggernaut
no let's try let's go skill they best do
let's look what they found out was stuff
they could act pd
you listen they respect the platform
they don't care about ninja
it'll be nice for the first month and I
remember PDC stronger this quick because
at that point mixer was bubbling as far
as he fun
yeah social presence in celebration is
over they do okay you're fine ninja and
Facebook in that contract he gonna dance
for the world but here's the big let's
shout out to them they're out for eatin
because they got this cuz of trouble
here's the question do we know what the
language of the contract is cuz this is
my whole got a hawk is like they got
their bread but let's be
by them going exclusive the mixer they
kind of damned their position of going
back to twitch especially I think I
don't think so man I'd really welcome
right back I think we're gonna come down
time and absolutely remember they got
some foul to him on the way out or mais
member they did Angela if it goes
anywhere its face it's not Facebook it's
a YouTube gaming he's not going back to
twitch the only I say they I think they
still bound to that contract his he said
affiliates is going over to Facebook
they get the option to side yeah yeah
you can go what you want if you want I
don't think if I gave you 50 million
dollars you got a option anything offer
he offered to buy out their contracts
they decline allow his both came out
openly and said that they don't have to
go anywhere they don't want to go so the
nature of their contracts they're
basically free agents there you bought
them out yeah the contracts done the
link to be this right X amount of years
on that contract right in a book was
probably gonna try to lowball those
years and say listen we give you all the
money we give you this amount of money
up front and we did two years off that
contract will probably be like 5 million
dollars or six million dollars oh and
then like no I'm not all my money so for
that six years you're gonna pay me all
that 50 and I'm gonna figure it out you
know well I I I'm pretty sure that's the
language that's in the contract that's
why you didn't take a buyout so kind of
like football don't want to be local
non-compete clauses or not probably so
probably so that's the question might be
why that that's why they probably have
kept their mouth shut
we gotta see let me know buzzer look
every day I'm sad though cuz you know
obviously I'd like to mix a platform I
like the class itself I like when it was
beam I like the latency I liked how the
interface was I loved that it was
integrated into the Xbox
I loved that aspect you know I promoted
streaming and it's gonna be sad to me
that even though they are transitioning
over the Facebook group and extra this
is a W for streaming for formatting so
that desire
but I was hoping that I know people
obably wouldn't want it but they would
at least try to put the Facebook
integration in so that the streamers
could still eat that you know on the
Xbox platform that was utilizing that
that part is a little you know kind of
crazy but at the end of the day yeah as
far as gonna be the winner here I mean
he got Instagram you got Facebook you
know clicking a button just to go to
your games like this is what to me
stadia was supposed to do and this to me
shows that you know dead rabbit like I
don't think they've outright seen it
okay they're not in gaming into that to
the box I mean right now like they're
like you know for right now mm-hmm
let's say you know right and let's see
how this stuff this dis partnership is
the relationship we just together I
don't know if I want you to you know
just got we just we dating
let's see how it goes from here and if I
really find that I really like you you
do all benefit to our relationship ring
on 360 like the HD DVD Drive they don't
work out you I'll shoot okay
you stupid listen I feel what you say I
mean at the end of the day I mean it's
just like I said it just sad cuz I what
competition twitches out twitch is out
of control you to actively use for all
my information and that's it but I want
to shout out to Louis out the Lord Lords
a gaming dotnet we got a great arm
articles called a joust where we have
two riders kind of go at each other and
in a respectful way and it was about
mixer is it a good thing for Microsoft
is it a bad thing for Microsoft that
kind of thing so check that out shout
the Lord Josh already editor-in-chief
and low mood art assistant editor
tremendous article man please check that
out and some poor Lords gave me that net
and they may both make compelling points
to everybody is saying the last thing
about the stores
yes offer would you man accolade they're
dead in retail bro they're dead in
retail a dead King is on to something
with this is trimming the fat season so
the way I look at
is your king's right like you after a
while you got to admit your problems al
and then if you fail you get out of
there and you consolidate and I rather
them beautiful focus all that you know
capital towards I guess the Xbox in in
the gaming situation and hopefully
that's what happens but that's what I
got oh what question know what question
I know this is probably gonna transition
in was I want to know because the
Microsoft stores was supposed to do is
lies that program called the all-access
which was you know you don't want to
retail budget you know pay-as-you-go and
you get the system up front and that was
the feature I believe that was
exclusively at Microsoft stores now
we're gonna transition into Phil's
interview but in Amazon Ryan's on your
right Amazon did have that you're right
PT so I just want to know how that's
handled now that the storefront is that
they're do they open it up to more
stores and know what this what they said
about um obviously the stores are going
away but in big cities they said they
were still gonna have like I don't know
what they're like Microsoft experienced
area and I'm hoping they're gonna be so
I don't know even the biggest stores
open like the NYC one that's like think
on Columbus Circle that's not going away
yeah but they transform in eight minutes
they stick right it's gonna be that
experiencing the experience sorry it's
not a retail no more like so yes so I
believe there's still be locations where
you could do that but yeah it's gonna be
hey the good thing about this is is this
the All Access program has always sort
of been under a rock like they've never
pushed that to the forefront right
actually many and as we transition into
the next topic you know filled so made
it very clear that that that was big
yeah let's do it
shares a [ __ ] right on it cuz we gotta
get this going and Delilah's man we
spent too long so we have a regulator
2,000 feet at twit shows buck snacks on
high fidelity savage there we are daily
gamer with the tennozu chat so it's
goodbye to mixer and it's great quality
and hello the monopoly known as twit
can't wait till the EU regulators get a
hold of twitch and I think myself
Microsoft was going to sell the mixer
tech to Facebook
interesting yeah sure the Americas
Microsoft may take no less qualitynet
jump so give me a second mm-hmm
okay so now we have a game is play with
the final super check or it has it at
Microsoft not all teams are treated
equally surface and Xbox are at odds
windows team is oblivious Phil is
fighting for us gamers I hope that's not
the kid gets the K that's crazy if it
would be together and we have JD gaming
with the files who chat nobody under 30
is checking for Facebook twenty to
thirty year olds tick-tock and snap to
them i'ma true kids move with the two
thousand which at rioters destroyed and
YC store and he closed them all to I
closed them all to beautiful store to
man he's been talking a lot everywhere
you go it's a new interview cake so I
wanted to bring King of Kings topic I
want to bring it to the realm um yeah
believe it was I've got the name of the
people global something that they hate
was it and goes globe lab yeah some to
that effect what fills out there and he
had a lot of stuff to say
so King where you at with this from the
Dominus okay um first let's uh give the
proper respect on let some respect on
that man's name Phil
Dominus Maximus princess soon to be
Aurelius yes is is a couple of talking
points that I'm gonna talk about I know
other people's gonna give their take on
the show my take on the interview the
show was um he said that he said there
were quiet confidence and he asked some
poignant questions questions we wanted
to know the complete answers to and you
know we got answers like okay well the
July show is gonna be about games be
about games you already showed you the
consoles no need to be worrying about
that um the underlining tone to it was
frame rate he mentioned frame rate at
ton of times and fidelity to explaining
to you how you would see the next
generation but he also told you to be
careful
because the next generation like I was
explaining to you guys it's going to be
a whole lot different than other
generations that we have because this
generation you have is really really
good mmm
you know from evidence of games like The
Last of Us you know stuff like
spider-man stuff like Gears of War Forza
you know in Halo 5s games of games of
these nature look fantastic so what we
need to do well what they need to do is
get the CPU up so this is where you're
going to see frame rates input lag and
stuff like that getting right back to
the gamer back to when we used to game
at 60 frames per second and then know
that twitch gameplay that arcade
gameplay that field that you controller
was off you know that feel so that's
what he's trying to get back the feel of
game to look of games is always going to
be at a high fidelity he also touched on
he wasn't afraid of what he saw actually
it was really good he could sound like
he was snickering King said that he saw
what other dudes were doing and he he
was what he says like I feel good about
so DJ about our stuff I feel real good
after what I saw um what he saw was the
chinks in the armor this is the first
time Microsoft gets to come from behind
mm this is the first time always Sony is
the accident champions by the ball of
other companies going first they come
from behind this is how we traded this
this is how we do this this is how oh we
don't have no DRM but it takes two hours
for your show to start
and it takes 24 hours for you to boot up
your system when you first got to go I
forgot great so this is a position that
he's very comfortable in and I I felt
all the energy that he had
confidence that he had strong your life
is going to show you nothing but those
game and he said we're about those games
and we're gonna let our game speak for
us what did you see from it I don't know
if addicts still he's cut his garavato
B's yeah I'm sorry yes get a dick bell
you know cuz we had everybody talk about
all this stuff a lot so annek bands like
what would you feel about the Dominus
outside talking I feel like he he's
confident there's no denying that one
thing that you know Phil's always been
very good at is not necessarily dodging
questions but if he feels like he
doesn't want to answer that question
he is like an expert at PR talk to not
answer that question and it just seems
like two years ago you would asked him
you know what do you think about the
competition
he would have dodged that question but
still gave a good answer so quick with
the quickness he never would have came
out to be like that that's cute hi
Angela like yeah that's literally what
he said he would have said something
like you know you know we have much
respect to Sony you know they've always
done what they done well and it's nice
to see you know he would've said
something around that he literally came
out like that's cute like I think that
you know I'm very confident what I have
to say mmm let's get a solvent we gotta
get you out of it we haven't talked
about this curious was soft - well yeah
man with the feel I agree with something
that access specifically is that I felt
that the points that stood out right
were in the obviously when he talked
about how he felt after watching the
PlayStation reveal and stuff like that
but I think a lot of the rest of the
interview would there was a lot of
verbal gymnastics going on oh are you
that happy was a dominant no no but it's
just he's a lot of the questions were
sort of regurgitation of questions he's
been asked before so it's like so a lot
of the stuff he was just reframing and
rephrasing things that he's sort of said
before and maybe he elaborated somewhat
more on them but again the verbal
gymnastics was there and he's very good
at that he's good at that like he was
gymnastic sir it was just when they when
they talk about like the general like
you know the idea and the theory behind
the series X and you know the game past
office that's all stuff that he's
answered in some way shape or form
before and he just sorta had to answer
it again right so again I'm not saying
he did he dodgeball he'll just say this
yeah it was a lot a lot of it felt like
filler because I've heard it before like
they were paying attention to every
primary name like so the stuff that
stood out to me was do two things in
particular right mhm
obviously the fact that he he came out
and said look I felt good about what we
have show in July um
because again it shows there's a
confidence there that they've taken the
the sort of missteps that they were took
you know that they will point it out
with the may reveal specifically for you
solve for you came for you I saw the dog
he's like so I was talking about that we
took the feedback so I'm anxious to see
gameplay from him just about I hope
everything they can they can viably show
gameplay for please show me gameplay for
um that would be fantastic so that's one
thing so I'm happy about that it has me
even more excited for the July event now
beyond that another thing that's
interesting to me that I've said this of
a number of times right when when he
when they asked him about how Sony goes
about business and and and there
anything right though was waiting for
the other day and to this guy goes right
he specifically said he says look
they're very good at what they do right
and they they did that we know what's
coming because they focused on that and
when he talks about that he talks about
you know basically what they consider
the Triple A to B how they how they
promote Triple A and what in their mind
is a Triple A game and how they know the
vast majority of the game sort of fall
within a certain mold and that's what
sells the platform right and he
specifically it's like okay that's what
they do that isn't necessarily what I do
and that struck me because again for
people on the Xbox side that are looking
for a you know a tit for tat like every
robbery every banger of theirs every got
a war there is gonna be met by one from
our side that isn't the case right
he specifically said I'm very happy with
the variety that we're gonna present and
you've been saying this for a long time
so again it's one of those things like
be be weary of if you're expecting to
see super bangers I'm reading super
beggars I'm not gonna I didn't think I
saw from that statement I took a
one-trick pony
oh yeah
that's that's one way to look at it but
the thing about it is I I think
obviously game past and and what it what
it brings to the table it allows these
smaller games that are still fantastic
games didn't be spotlighted right about
the three C's yeah what do you say the
species were they were community
community cloud or something
cloud whatever we mess it up the book
acts right maybe consoles like that so
we messed it up continued JRE said
that's where sir computers well this is
the thing right because this is the way
I feel right no make no question we want
to win we're on to win right and I think
by changing the conversation and game
path between what it is right it's
different right it's it's different and
and it keeps them in the game in a
different way that PlayStation isn't
even thinking about right but I feel at
the end of the day right if you really
want to win like if you want to take
over number one you have to beat the
market leader at their own game I wish
you I think I got me I had to audit
argument about that and I think you
oughta something I said to say God wait
till we do a show when it come to right
at when we do a preview show when they
see when they announce this day trust me
I'll guys start on so do I do I hope and
think fable is humongous game triple-a
bang I hope and pray that what it is for
a same thing if the perfect dark rumors
are true and if it's a third person you
don't reboot if that is that fantastic I
would want to do all of that um but I
just think you know on the Sony side
everything that's coming out of their
main studios is
to be in that sort of their their
triple-a wrapper right if you don't
match them game for game and and knows
you know we can say whatever we feel
about Metacritic those medic Rick
there's no matter right the conversation
is gonna be the same as it's always been
but so I still think at some point you
have to meet your opponent on the
battlefield when you say meet your
opponent on the battlefield
oh you mean it what specifically with
that meeting so do games like Xbox one
Xbox what on Xbox directly competes with
that like nothing that nothing could
directly complete their game nicely look
so I know yeah let's keep it a book
that's new bit about yeah the
conversation that he spoke about let's
do this let's tell the truth was shame
the devil
just told you he didn't even see them as
compared to see said no disrespect to
those dogs over there no disrespect to
Sony and Nintendo you know I I grew up
on them a nice no disrespect to them I
respect what they did right no
disrespect to them but we're in a whole
different game plan right now I'm
worrying about Google and Amazon feel
that what he said I will help them out
we're giving them you know cloud
services we've talked about them right
babe they this is the pincer move right
attacking them they attacking him from
different ways right and in there
they're making headway in that regard
when it comes to the toe-to-toe in the
head it's Conan I've been a contest it's
not in the contest every double down so
cuz I had this is a beat shot the forte
if he in here cuz he was witness to me
and addict had with a drag down
knockout fight and it is called two days
ago and basically they Kate I've given
you our preview of my topic when it
comes out come to the show basically the
argument was he said Cobb I have
Jew specifically what do you need from
Xbox to win this show
I want a show to be a success to July
show and I said look I'm expecting halo
in a lot of this stuff right I'm
expecting quality of expecting some some
bangers and stuff we didn't heard about
but I specifically said and I got killed
for this I need one third-person
over-the-shoulder narrative cinematic
experience game so I was told I'm asking
for too much cuz look at the studios and
maybe they working on this and we're
good on that and I said you don't signed
all these Studios you got all these
genres we see that the leader is doing
this genre and winning with that genre
you can't give me one of those games
where there'd be compulsion we've had on
IOP maybe I don't listen up I want
quality am I expecting it to be on the
level of the Last of Us I'm not saying
it I mean that they may be in another
stratosphere with that but I want a copy
they even got days going over there a
lot of people still like you don't say
it like I just want one you want no no
no Dalila hold on let me let me get
y'all I know y'all going with this car
car with the hell blade listen I agree
with y'all here's the problem Sony fans
don't agree with y'all cuz you know what
they say they say always tailgaters are
fours already or they'll say well hell
blade don't come I'm just telling you
what the fanboy rules are so y'all know
right
the fanboy rule say hello hail blade -
don't count because oh it existed on
another platform it's not a new idea on
the own room right they want a new IP
I'm telling you fanboy well don't get
mad at me I'm just explaining what the
rules are to the fanboys so all I would
like to me that they would they would
shut up a lot of people if it was a new
IP third-person over-the-shoulder
cinematic experience and blew everything
out of it and it's a quality game and
the reason why I say this is because
let's be real right Xbox one came out x2
the OG xbox halo was the flagship 360
you could say Gears was the flagship
let's be real y'all Xbox one what was
defiant flagship there was blood I mean
no
disrespect to Ori no disrespect I'm just
I'm talking about from a new IP that the
character that carries you into the new
generation they so all obviously I agree
with you Roz could have been one right
wrong dude that was in charge all I'm
saying is when the wrong dude is in
charge he can mess up a whole bunch of
stuff and so you had those dudes right
that was in place for a long time right
you know those dudes literally were
there from the beginning all the way
through right yo me with the fanboy
rules I'm telling y'all yeah I don't
agree with I'm just telling you if you
know what it is if you want that side to
buy your system this is what they
telling me I listen that's not like we
can say what we want we can say there's
one a guy's going to buy a $200 console
when it come out dollars is that they
don't they have no whew you I only
respect four million
I just feel if gave us one of those that
was shut up a lot of people I'm telling
you I'm giving you Phil I'm giving you
the playbook baby exactly my book oh
yeah do is give one and that desk or
shut up every we've know the reality the
third party game show as far as the
games is fire
we know they they got fire stuff for a
deck discount just give one new IP
third-person narrative over this show
watch what's going to happen watch how
the narrative is gonna shift and
everybody gonna shut up and then it's
gone I'm telling you I'm telling you
know what after that's like I don't
wouldn't happen King what's the problem
that's gonna happen that's okay I love
the master mind that is in position now
yeah right because what a real general
does is take away your shrimps or fix
his weaknesses to make them strengths
mhm so you don't think he looks at the
catalogue and say you know compares
catalog the same
Wow okay so this is where they are with
this okay so they didn't respect this
okay so they did dig all right okay
let's fix this let's fix that oh they
came in on price I don't care what
anybody say I believe the budget dude
the budget dude is running the bank out
their budget nude is the Gus that's the
first full platform that you must win on
first you went on power that resolution
stuff is over so you already see now
that these dudes is talking well can
they take they take it around let's do
some different okay do something
different because you can you do power
do something different okay so you can't
do price I know for a fact your price is
gonna be too high and you're gonna lose
in price once you lose in price there's
only four million dudes over there
that's really buying notice every time
they games hit is them same full moon
dude it's never the hundred with a
twenty it's four million goofy but at
the same time watch your casual dudes
purchase the next generation joint
there's cheaper and the fast casual
brothers right the call about that at
all that game is going to be there III
think this is strong sure I'm not
doubting them I'm just telling you how
you win this wall all the way around
that's all I'm saying do you solve all
right now to get that is the thing you
win this war by beating them at their
own game any show that you can do it I
don't think they would I don't think
they're design ethos is gonna be like
we're gonna match some game for game so
but at the very least be like look we
can do we can do that too and it's a
quality game yeah sometimes you gotta
call the fraud on people that's like all
the diversity that ever diversity but at
the end of the day the only place on top
again exactly hey madam exactly and they
did their town all this game past
diversity but they don't clear all of
that stuff like I hear mad people know
so I'm so excited about the ascent of
the ascent at the launch yo cool
at the launch you'll get the ascent
because it shows the power of the system
right and in a certain way
and it's there at launch let me see how
you wrap the ascent to two years later
and if that doesn't fall to the wayside
because at that point you don't need
that game anymore right so this is what
I'm talking about is like if you really
care about the diversity you're gonna
get what he's talking about and
everything that comes down the pipeline
will it be from sitting in exile
whatever you're gonna love that because
you're going to get different
experiences let me go I'm sorry but that
you know that's not how you necessarily
win over everyone no I hear what you say
I get what case I gotta get meds I gotta
get home what you call it hold on hold
on it come up we gotta we gotta be super
champion we can I get the super chair
Jonathan B I feel you I'm just telling
you how the rules go in this change Zack
I didn't make the rules I'm just telling
you what the people are saying and I
agree I'm just telling you what they say
but let's catch the super-sized we gotta
get meds and we got it smoothie smoothie
smooth with the fire are super Chatfield
ominous we want to play we want players
to hear the game is not the console
today we are Gerald gerald magnifier
also pitch at hashtag hardware advances
we got drunken ninja with the fight off
switch at Xbox to clap back buy things
60 frames per second makes you a better
game I help you out JD game with $10 up
chef bill isn't giving Sony the plans of
attack this time he waiting to sneak up
behind them and say this is the back of
decide 12 12 5 this is a great race now
tell me g5 don't matter yeah Rodriguez
the $10 to protect we are here talking
about games and power when 90% of people
buy the system's their friends are on
and it's true cross way and pricing are
more important once FIFA and Rainbow six
go cross-platform then you'll see up and
at GTA it's funny because we laugh at
the GTA 5 thing but it is the biggest
property ever like game was play Phil
dominus is showing his swagger her Xbox
series s Locke are being the same speed
as a series X
whoa price is the definer no doubt we
got jumped crazy play okay then we have
JD JD $10 super chat Microsoft is about
to drop game bomb after bomb after bomb
in July supported by Xbox series X power
next part series s price superior
services game pass X cloud be ready for
all-out war hashtag Sony losing market
share both o that we got job then be
2010 the same fanboys so any first party
don't sell 100 mil but FIFA does pics of
my brother picks it with G finalized a
check your cog is keeping it on it they
need a game that has pretty pictures and
a story attached you have to have it you
know because they give up give them that
walk is all I say it was one Oh Jay Paul
I gotta get you are safe re $10 Suzette
Celina building we want quality games a
finished product day one not on the
finished games with unfinished stories
that will finish with David come on gray
bar yeah I gotta give it to burrito
because Bari has come on our show and he
always says yo I caught them no he drops
and then I get disgusted by them he does
know you know Jay you're 100% right in
and you represent the 1% of your
community and what I want you to do is
tell that to the other 20% get 20% to
purchase that glass because you want
quality I feel you you got quality with
the last was apparently the fan base
don't got that though yeah it's your boy
many people or matter P with the two
dollars to protect preach King no that's
right brother let me getting one bad
mother-- finest which at thro fanboy
rules in the bushes just to be great
fighters could win with different styles
Microsoft right make they fighting sadly
I feel that they gotta give now as a
high quality game what it up styles
gotta be a banger well that's all I'm
saying
it's gotta be gotta be all around bang
another you know some you know listen to
me give stack this is a fantastic Ginga
absolutely not everybody's playing
against what
say and not everybody's playing a book
get a party to kick you while we caught
up gamer 2010 new upcoming add Xbox does
what PlayStation don't sixty yeah Alex
with the fight off super check if they
don't show any gameplay itself actual
jewel fact though that's a fact
perfect Shogun to awesome chat Jesse the
support to the greatest pot clutch man
with the fight also pits here we go
ladies doesn't try to beat BMW in sporty
looks no one can deny the luxury of a
Benz box its locking down more Lux
digital found e-brake digital crown
breakdown yeah I feel you here's what
I'm saying but if your competitor is
offering that new feature that turbo
feature that the fares like you could
put that feature that one feature oh and
you know Bob are you talking about the
hardware breakdown you know when the
thirty friends when they target in 1440p
and 30 frames per second and then you
know xbox is doing true 4k and 60 frames
per second or 120 frames per second and
the games just looking that much Chris
spinners and it's cheaper to see the
Sony fan I know you these are the DS of
the PlayStation simple guys the slip you
know why you got the pro guys you know
why I say this you know why I say this
4,000,000 brought pros 4,000,000 brought
the last of us right the rest of you
guys brought that PlayStation cuz it was
$100 cheaper I don't care about that I
ain't got $100 to be spending like that
this is $200 cheaper man I know you
dudes man I know your wallet and your
wallet don't look right in that like
definitely 100% getting that damn
Lockhart and I know for a fact he's
targeting you access the lock on the
gate fast no it's for the broke do so
they don't get it okay
did you look at his strategy this
strategy 100% is yo you got credit you
got no money we pay $30 a month to get
in it
what can you said what okay yo you can't
afford $600 to get to series X mm I got
some food is saying is that Lord fill
Dominus maximum notorious Spencer he got
the premium gamers like King color and
he got the boys covered everybody's in
the club for everybody and then you got
game pass so all you frauds right now
destroy borrowing again for less you're
lying you didn't buy because if you did
it then it'd have been 20 million so
it's not 20 million sold it's full I
respect you for million days I respect
you all you pro owners all you do I
respect you guys so much because we
together here I was playing in 4k I was
doing that I was doing a cheap dues that
cheap out and didn't buy it and so on my
timeline you're getting a lock hard they
have to fight them toe-to-toe sounds
like you've never seen floor made with a
box King and battle you don't have to
meet the opponent on the floor for armed
I think you've missed the analogy sir
tell me this like to be Floyd Mayweather
do you have to step into the ring yes
beat him at his own game to be floor man
with it you can't stand outside and say
I beat for a minute
shut out the world me with the pylon
super chat just wanted you to read
another suit absolutely we continue will
me bet for you that's it we got a more
10 more
squirrely down the only turbo in the
past are all the fans take a seat so I
would say like a turbo should be all of
June he covered for me that steel for me
then we got during an interview at
Palmetto more than ever we will see it
mmm okay Jonathan let me get you because
I don't come from me he's John find some
chat only Sony can have 10% of a fan
base buy something and consider it a
success if I'm sorry baby I use a blade
say I got Adobe blaze you get city Smith
can I get a la carte please stop do what
I do it I think I see boom up in the
building was gonna boo bear yo gamers
play don't care them cake they said yeah
alright I want them to cry bro Lord want
you to quiet the keyboard right now Lord
beds Lord treaty I got a goodbye y'all
real quick because if we go along um
what did you take I got a brief yeah
Phil Dominus is Joe no shame did you
talk interview I mean listen I'm with
him I think foot on neck is coming I got
to disagree with you though uh cog
because I don't want that third person
over to sort of crabby I could keep that
keep that I was having a discussion with
my friend and yours def single last
night is not today we were discussing
this because we he was you know praising
well the diversity are on Xbox
and then trashing the you know the
typical third-person over-the-shoulder
whatever all right um
and I told them listen Sony can afford
not to have diversity because they have
de facto second party exclusives that
they're just exclusive for no reason
like persona um judgment things like
that where make like third-party
developers don't really make that Sony
style game too often so they have the
gap in the market to fill and then the
rest of the diversity comes from the
second party exclusive exclusive
Microsoft doesn't have these defective
second party exclusive so they're kind
of pigeon-holed into giving the people
diversity because if they don't who will
you know right so so I'm I agree with
you to a certain extent but keep that
over the show third person
if halo if it is third person I am going
to flip the second party exclusives fall
into that mold to yeah they had they had
neo one Andrea when it to mmm they've
had um they had yeah who's up until now
right and they had judgment they all
sort of fall into that mold like tell me
tell me a third party exclusive persona
right personified that's one that's
different it's an RPG a lot of RPGs
Dragon Quest it didn't come to Xbox did
it right a lot of Japanese support
really is kind of what I'm getting at oh
you want him to make sure that the
Japanese support picks up we saw you
cool and alloy game yeah I think that
was huge yeah I thought that was huge
too
I thought that was you all I'm saying is
just one that's all I'm saying I give
how do you think they could give me a
vertical initiative could give slice of
something down the room I'm gonna give
you something right now give me some
bigger ninja okay
listen that's a no no no nobody help Lee
hey listen listen no no no no count okay
listen take care how you like it yeah a
ninja oh I think I know are you going I
think I know what you're going I heard
about that I don't want to get gas cuz
we'll we do yes yeah yeah I heard about
that
if you can do that that is definitely
yes good I doubt I heard about that and
you know I'm the ninja you know that's
what I do so this is that is true pick
me out of the group there
Miller I heard I heard about this people
I heard about the week we can't talk too
much but I heard um let's get the
actually beds finish I know we got
supercharged no I know
minutes finish it boy yeah I'm done you
can move on okay finish your boss I'll
be I'll be quick slow the video I
thought it pretty much with Phil saying
was pretty much what you expected him to
say but you know I thought it was you
know generally he was just giving you
guys general information of what's been
going on but it's it's like right there
and then so it's something to kind of
keep you guys on that little Xbox
you know rope also be a finesse SOG
apply okay good yeah yeah sure people
remember in the back of her head that
the xbox is coming so it was more like a
promotional thing to kind of keep
people's tour yeah that's that's it was
just another thing that he was going
through but I think that I wish we could
see some of those first party programs
like you were saying yeah like or at
least a little rumblings or something or
be like hey guys we're definitely
working on first party programs with
these companies or something because
that would be nice for people that
normally don't want to buy one like
right I don't plan on buying a ps5 I
don't plan online
yeah I don't know I have no reason to
buy one of those so if you tell me that
you got an exclusive game that it's for
the Xbox series X mm maybe I'll think
about it maybe wants you to stay on your
PC and just give me if he's gonna give
me the same games on PC okay I said
father's bug spy no doubt he definitely
for you oh let's get the super chest so
I solve it then I'll get my balls up
there we out of here John new eat with
the $2 super chat let me let me get buck
snacks for the co best to it was a guy
that was before the King speaks the
truth support those incredible gamers
let's go the book of eggs holla let's go
over see you some super bunny sir
see you Friday stir-friday King Monday
Colerain no support the brother you know
say and they get JD game I saw got JD
gaming with the $2 super chat new ad
power you can feel 60 francs the second
and cheaper to we all good on is one
more element oh I love it is this it
your to get elevator feel we need some
it Agha key juice in July's hmm let's
hold that Lindsay I say yeah we go we
can't talk about it
hmm we'll see we'll see oh look man I'll
get miss quick you know we had a lot of
stuff I know the realm it's not happy
with me it's off right now cuz yeah I'm
sorry I'm sorry y'all know you know
you're not reppin all of them games yes
you guys listen listen at the other day
I got off that bar I bought that square
we'll talk about that when we do our
July preview show for the event we'll
get into that what we expect about this
film
dominus in a billion laughs he's outside
man he's outside it's comfortable
he's moving and I like it I like it I
like it when you know this how I look at
things at some point if you've been
bullied is it for a generation
you've had enough you've had enough so
everything that they feel as a perceived
strength you know or that the opponent
that they see the opposition they trying
to take away from them like Kings say
and I like it I like I like the
aggressive that you gotta deliver down
cuz you're talking you're talking a lot
talk a lot man but you guys live out he
went in on the sound of the console
they're being noisy over there you don't
say he went him you know I'm saying that
yo you know um he saw they show he
wasn't really he's flexing he's flexing
no doubt to me this how I look at it
when you have the game awards right and
you set off hell blade at the game
awards right that means you got in my
opinion you got the gun or tuck like
that that's just a warning shot to let
dudes know what's going on if you come
outside that's how I look at because you
could have saved that fur for this July
and then we'd have been crazy so if you
busing off with that I'm like okay now
everybody was mad at the July show
name your own issue I mean a base show
begin third party excuse me not like
that
cuz I said let this ha say yeah Japanese
support like our majors talking about
right that they never had as well you
coos all launched things that I never
know what I would see
I saw a third party joins now yes you
could get on the gameplay but this what
this is how I took it
if you got all these games that you had
to have a separate show for just this
what else you got it talk right so to me
that's confidence to me that's like the
kid who studied for the tests he's ready
to take the test he he's he's ready he's
he's he's so transparent about you know
talking to you and that's how I look at
him right now he's ready
the question is he's gotta deliver them
right he's got it he's got to go down
and finish the job
the layup is there like it was it the
Patrick you it's there to dunk the
basketball you saw these dudes you said
you wasn't impressed even some Sony fans
you had blazed on and blazes like look
if blaze kept to the buck it was like
look if they didn't show the console at
the end I would have been upset a lot of
people said this and this is not just
cap I've seen this from some Sony fans
so my whole thing is now you got to do
you got to do the take now you know say
now you got to bring it home I'm excited
for July I want to see what they do and
that's it I thought it was a cool you
know and the last thing I like I will
say this I love the priority on frame
rates I love that he is taking the
narratives from you know Sony's little
by little the back compact they're
banging them with the small delivery
they're banging them with the you know
I'm saying so disjointed is dope to me I
want Frank's that's what I'm about you
know I'm saying yaki the 4k is cute but
you give me an M 60 frames that's what
I'm talking about and plus 120 I'm with
that so let's go was what I took from
this is my clothes your clothes on yeah
you guys missed the biggest most
important smack to the back of Sony's
head our box is predictable see I cut
that Howard there's no fluctuation I got
there's no juggling mmm what you get is
that real raw you get that 100% uncut
I like this other dudes over there got a
cut in step one in the movie two side
it's on was a now games
what was that who was that mo was that
Jason Ronald's I don't Jason Ronald kind
of really wanna kind of going back
fighting back trapping back with the SSD
talk yeah I'm not trying to take the L
on the SSD talk but we yeah you know we
go hit we're gonna hopefully hear more
from him but um yeah I mean it's gonna
be it's gonna be a good looks at the
other day our game is just gonna be a
battle y'all it's gonna be a fun battle
let's see how this thing on play let's
get the super chests and get up out of
here because we keep the same energy
Microsoft comes with over the shoulder
banger the match Sony you know how high
fans would be that's what I'm saying
don't they have a lot of people happy
Gerald Mac with the final switch at
looks like Microsoft got tired of so
many bullying Xbox and now it's Sony's
Microsoft Microsoft backing Xbox all the
way big big cold Bill Gates it was like
just by some studios new joint with the
recent teasing of Halo Infinite by three
for three
ahead of minus of July event how
important is halo showing actus event to
the overall success of the July showcase
the choices are a critical if halo
infinite is a dud throw series X and 3
for 3 in the bushes Xbox Syria series as
could still survive if infinite is
mediocre because Microsoft first-party
could deliver with beggars or see I
don't care as long as halo if Network
unlike Master Chief collection salute to
the Chad salute to everybody shoot the
Lord asks a little turnaround for coming
together for attic and it's cause that
was beautiful
solution Lord PD and Lord maspeedy
coming in put the foot of the grave of a
platform to get his bars off and love
this bob boogie down bro you already
know my MMA guy
let's get these saddles managed to start
with PD style TV what's up man what
could a Fonzie what's going on bro do
you find me every day on on Twitch if
you're looking if you're looking to find
me find me it's now though TV SN al why
do TV Monday to Friday from 7:00 to
11:00 I'm there go check it out I'm on
Twitter discord all those places and I
actually have a little bit of a right
now a poll going okay with the guys from
wicker your gaming also looked good with
with the guys because we're been arguing
about a crab rangoon because we've never
even I've never heard of them before
they swear that it's just a thing that I
don't know so I'm putting up I'm putting
the link no I heard of that either bro I
don't know thank you is like right it's
like a it's like a little tortilla like
[Music]
put that poem because they don't believe
me that I told them that most people do
not know what the heck they are this is
gonna going through thing all week to
the point where they've even written
articles of all on them on their website
so it is gone intense so I'm just want
to get legit answers from people so
thank you guys for letting me come on
solve addicts where you are not here
King you guys yeah I miss you guys play
crafts this year no been too long since
all of us have gotten together so yeah
we would have been there probably around
the speaker last week or around right
around now so hopefully we gonna get
together during the summertime for at
least two months and drinks and sit by
the pool or some afternoon I got to go
down what stays get Dorma lies
we definitely got linked up again and of
course brolo of meds back in the realm
in a minute you gonna say tell people
quite wait what you got going on where
they could find you what's poppin room
for sure just again thanks for having me
on
I love talking to my Bronx brothers and
a PD YouTube and also I just want
everybody to follow me over there and
twitch.tv slash that's right King twitch
TV slash actually met um I'm gonna be
streaming persona 4 golden later on PC
beautiful port and also I do a little
MMA talk yeah twice tune in for me I do
that live alright we'll talk about
breakdown twitch.tv slash actually meds
okay and catch me on there talking all
the fights we break things down talk
about the future and Brea analyze the
fights everything that's going down and
also I just really hope that this Kovac
stuff blows over people wear your masks
yes so that mini and the iron Lords can
go out and review some movies reviewing
bushes we can't go outside and meet
whenever old matches one of our regular
bros we would hit up hit the favorite
because you know it's movie to movie
depending on the managers is there that
made is whether you can do it or not
probably a sponsorship that's what we do
on you know saying the dark files which
I imagine a solo as a new Xbox to do
they got ninja Terry level skills a
plague tale to build schools ap series X
would be amazing I'm a little misfire
you ain't tell ya they are firemen
you know I'm gone right now I'm going to
hopefully I'll get back early enough to
play some LA and yes we doing you know I
hope that King and attic can postpone
their or the cast not gonna have that
we're gonna go
we laundry here I'll do me like you did
the way out goods and it's now - of
course man yeah miss miss just hanging
out with the bros man King on his square
well first of all I would like to give a
shout out to our esteemed guest people
don't understand how hard I lean on PD
post um for when cog is you know cog
there's a lot of work during the week
and sometimes when Kos has to go up
ahead PD up and yo PDS on his square you
know you see me joking around with him
that's just jokes me he's my guy
the train ride that's my guy oh yeah
haven't got a chance to meet meds in
person but you know hopefully we can do
a roundtable review and comms I'm coming
and definitely get to do that hopefully
we can go watch a fight together there's
me you and ground the gamer we're
supposed to do our thing so hopefully
that comes into fruition as well um Kos
to be up this week you see the box right
there
I have a poll up right now wrong and the
poll is what statue you want me to unbox
is the mouse Morales or Premium Format
is the spider-man Peter Parker
spider-man and it's the ultimate Captain
America pre please go the the poll is
gonna be off for the next three days and
also go to on Dolph castles X channel
and subscribe there Fridays I do a
statue podcast I'm there you talk games
you talk statues we talk a whole bunch
of stuff and please all the Lords of
gaming down that I'm going I can't keep
saying it too much I mean I just give
myself to Lord of gaming but they do so
much phenomenal work and the writing is
it's top-notch I mean trust me I'm not
just saying it I want you to just check
it if you go look at it and if you don't
like it
that's wack King no man no trust we just
go out and if you like it just just do
that thumbs up please not to Lord gene
or gene like a breakdown of the
cyberpunk
night city wire like that Wow
like it really if you did not get to
watch it just read that and you will be
informed a lot of a lot of the writers
that we have they do all those deep
dives and I'm really like personal so
it's like it's not like just regular
like writers that are just like writing
to write its writers that are passionate
about what they're doing and the reviews
that they read and everything team
lookout also show we got some things
coming out for them because I got I got
to support my guys man so we look be
able to look out for some pneuma but
I'll give a bunch of yeah be also look
out for so merciful for numerous for
lock net we're trying to do something
cool for them because again these guys
they kill it every week let's get gay
with my choice real quick soft ok my
choice great show and discussion thank
you sir much appreciate thank you long
when you are everybody enjoy your Sunday
we're gonna leave you all with the King
we got that promote and who did that for
y'all sweepstakes everybody enjoy your
Sunday we out of here and we're bringing
to you an exciting new giveaway this
giveaway is like none other
we'll be giving away an Xbox series X
that's right you heard me right the
brand new console launching from
Microsoft this year well this is how
you're able to be part of that giveaway
there's two ways to get your name thrown
in the head for the raffle one become a
member of the realm
that's that joy button hit hit that joy
button you hit that joint button down at
the bottom and you can become a member
and also another way is by becoming a
patreon member so you can be part of the
realm as well now this is brought to you
by cat daddy fat stacks
a member and lord of the realm a very
generous person that's in our community
and this community is beautiful so
remember you can have one entry by
hitting that joint button and becoming a
member of the realm and also you can
have another entry by being a patreon
now you said King what if I'm a member
of both well your name gets thrown in
the Hat two times so please like follow
us subscribe join or become a patreon
member or become both and your name is
in the Hat to get that Xbox series X as
to who did their for you
sweepstakes this is wonderful this is
something that I'm sure that you will
enjoy